Und damit recht herzlich willkommen zu einem letzten Donnerstag im Monat aus einem Blue Moon Studio von Fritz, was natürlich heißt, dass der Chaos Computer Club und anverlannte Menschen zu Gast sind, um über ein Thema zu berichten, das irgendwie mit diesen neuartigen Rundfunkumfangsgeräten zu tun hat, vor denen ihr wahrscheinlich gerade sitzt. Wir sprechen von Computern. Ich begrüße heute recht herzlich den Herrn Erdgeist. Hallo und guten Abend.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Die Nana. Hallo und guten Abend. Ah, vielleicht müsste ich noch die Mikrofone aufmachen. Die Nana, hallo und guten Abend. Und die Marie. Das Chaos Radio hat den Namen nicht umsonst. Das heißt nicht etwa so, weil der Chaos Computer Club da dabei ist, sondern weil es immer sehr chaotisch zugeht. Wir wollen heute über Programmieren lernen reden. Und da hört mein Verständnis quasi schon auf, weil ich ja gar nicht so genau weiß, wie man das im Radio machen will. Da sitzen ja Leute vor Computern und tippen da was und dann passieren irgendwie Dinge. Deswegen würde ich die lieben Gäste und Gästinnen mal bitten zu erklären, was genau meint ihr denn, wenn ihr sagt, wir reden heute über Programmieren lernen, also diese Programmieren lernen. Was ist das eigentlich? Was ist Programmieren, Herr Erdgeist?
Programmieren findet bei mir eigentlich zu 90 Prozent irgendwo auf dem Klo statt, wo man über Probleme nachdenkt. Naja, es ist wichtig, dass man ein Problem, was einem präsentiert wird, in handliche Teilprobleme zerlegt und ungefähr eine Vorstellung davon hat, welche Probleme davon schon gelöst sind, welche Werkzeuge man dazu benutzt und was man noch selber machen muss. Und die zehn Prozent Zeit, die dann noch über bleibt, ist dann wirklich hinzuschreiben, was über bleibt. Das ist für mich Programmieren.
Aber jetzt hast du schon sozusagen vorausgesetzt, dass ich weiß, was da bei dem Hinschreiben passiert?
Na, ich sagte ja, was ich glaube, was für mich Programmieren ist. Und dieses Hinschreiben ist dann einfach nur dieses Handwerkszeug, was man dann irgendwann mal sich angeeignet hat auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Und ja, diese Tätigkeit ist dann Programmieren, das Hinschreiben. So, dass andere Leute fangen mit dem Hinschreiben an und lernen so Syntax, also wie so eine Programmiersprache aus.
Was ist Programmieren? Also sagen, das ist nicht die Erklärung, die sozusagen alles gleich mitmacht, sondern was ist Programmieren? Also ganz zusammengedampft.
Programmieren ist, glaube ich, Probleme auf elektronischem Weg zu lösen.
Na gut, Nana, was ist Programmieren?
Programmieren ist einfach dem Computer sagen, was er jetzt machen soll, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das finde ich eine gute Beschreibung. Für mich sind auch, ich lese gerade so ein Buch, da geht es ganz viel um wie Computer denken und wie man sich das so vorstellen kann. Und da wird auch ganz viel von Problemen gesprochen, was Erdgeist gerade auch angesprochen hat. Und für mich ist Programmieren immer auch eher so eine Sache, die dir Möglichkeiten eröffnet. Also eher tatsächlich, denk da gar nicht an Probleme.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht was macht Programmieren, was kann Programmieren, welche Ebenheit Programmieren, sondern was ist Programmieren?
Aber dann tatsächlich vielleicht einfach Ideen mit dem Computer lösen.
Also, und falls ihr, also ihr habt jetzt alles schon ganz blumig beschrieben, aber der eigentliche Akt des Programmierens ist doch, ich schreibe Buchstaben in einem Computer, in einem Textdokument und dann sozusagen sind das wie Nana gesagt hat, quasi Befehle an den Computer. Ist das erstmal richtig?
Über Umwege ja. Also du sagst ja dem Computer das auch über seine Werkzeuge, meistens einem Compiler, der dir dabei hilft, deine Sprache.
Ja, aber wenn ich programmiere, dann schreibe ich Buchstaben in ein Dokument und was ich da reinschreibe sind quasi Befehle.
Nicht wirklich, es gibt andere Möglichkeiten. Du kannst auch mit der Maus klicken, du kannst auch, weißt du? Du sagst dem Computer auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise, sprich nichts dagegen, mit dem Computer natürlich sprachlich zu kommunizieren, das ist auch programmieren. Oder mit der Maus irgendwie Verbindungen von irgendeinem Recht weg zu einem anderen Recht weg zu ziehen, um ihn zu beschreiben, was er tun soll. Du musst ihm aber beschreiben, was er tun soll, weil der Computer das von selber nicht weiß. Der kann, je nachdem, was ist für eine Maschine.
Okay, ich sehe schon, wir haben hier Juristen. Also programmieren ist also dem Computer Befehle mitteilen. Ja, so weit erst mal richtig. Also Befehle in eine Liste tun. Das kann man auf vielfältige Art und Weise machen, also zum Beispiel mit der Maus klicken. Aber zum größeren Teil der Zeit passiert das, indem Leute Texte über eine Tastatur eingeben. Oder Zahlen, Zeichen. Zeichen, Zeichen. Also ihr seht, es wird heute kompliziert. Wir möchten ja sozusagen, dass das vor allen Dingen die Leute verstehen, die noch nicht programmieren können. Und die können auch gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 120 und Fragen stellen. Wenn ihr irgendwas hört, wo ihr denkt, also ich habe es fast verstanden, aber nicht ganz ruft an, fragt nach, wir wollen es heute ganz klar machen. Oder wenn ihr gerade programmieren lernt und eine Geschichte dazu erzählen wollt, erstens, warum ihr das gemacht habt und b vielleicht, wie es euch gelungen ist, wie ihr das gemacht habt, könnt ihr auch gerne anrufen 0331 70 97 110. So und wir reden ja heute hier über das Programmieren lernen, weil es so ein, also es gibt ja Menschen, die sagen alle sollen das machen, Schulunterricht etc pp. Ihr sagt zumindest, das ist nicht ganz unwichtig, das kann man vielleicht können wollen.
Warum?
Marie, warum ist Programmieren lernen wichtig oder Programmieren können wichtig?
Also ich kann nicht für andere sprechen, wie so das wichtig sein kann. Ich finde viele andere Sachen auch sehr wichtig. Ja, Jura ist auch sehr wichtig. Es gibt auch sehr wichtige Geisteswissenschaften. Das ist alles sehr wichtig und auch sehr nützlich. Ich finde aber tatsächlich Programmieren deswegen auch wichtig, weil ich das Gefühl habe, es gibt sehr wenige Menschen, die denken, dass sie programmieren, dass sie das können sollten und die das dann tatsächlich auch nicht können. Dafür gibt es aber sehr viel in deiner alltäglichen Umwelt, was mit Programmieren zu tun hat. Das finde ich extrem schade, dass es so wirklich so ganz wenig Wissen darüber gibt, aber ganz viel Einfluss auf deinen Alltag nimmt. Deswegen fände ich das irgendwie besser, wenn mehr Leute programmieren können.
Damit sie ihre Umwelt verstehen.
Ich denke auch, dass Programmieren eine Möglichkeit sein kann, dass man ein Konzept davon entwickelt, was eigentlich die Computer machen. Und ich denke auch, dass das einen Platz hat, auch in der Schule zum Beispiel, dass halt genauso wie man Grundlagen der Physik in der Schule lernt oder Grundlagen der Chemie, dass man einfach auch verstehen lernt, wie funktioniert sowas ungefähr? Wie kann ich den Computer dazu bringen, dass er macht oder ungefähr das macht, was ich möchte, dass er macht?
Na für mich ist es zweigestalt. Einerseits würde ich total gerne wollen, dass Menschen den Computer nicht als so ein magisches Ding mit einer eigenen Persönlichkeit, den man vielleicht irgendwie noch so ein Buddha oben draufstellen muss, damit er nicht abstürzt oder damit der Drucker mal druckt, sondern das als ein deterministisches Etwas, eine nur Befehle ausführende, die auch sehr komplex sein können, aber nur eine Befehle ausführende Maschine ist, die man verstehen kann und die hoffentlich jemand verstanden hat, der es zusammengebaut hat und einem dieses Mündigkeitsgefühl wieder gibt, da nicht ausgeliefert zu sein, dass dieser Kasten schon irgendwas macht und am Ende alles gut wird, sondern dass ich weiß, wo ich drücken muss, dass ich weiß, wer sich vielleicht was dabei gedacht hat, Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen schwierig, das zusammenzuschrauben, sodass man dem wieder selber mündig gegenüber steht. Dazu muss man nicht unbedingt programmieren können. Ich finde aber auch wichtig, dass man programmieren kann, weil so ein Computer einem verdammt viel Arbeit abnehmen kann, die man tagtäglich hat. Und wenn man es schafft, die Probleme, die einem da über den Weg zu laufen, so um zu formulieren, dass der Computer die für einen lösen kann, dazu muss man nicht unbedingt programmieren im Sinne von eine Programmiersprache beherrschen. Es gibt Menschen, die einfach in Excel oder ihrem Spreadsheet-Programm der Wahl so komplexe Algorithmen auch hinschreiben, dass ich das einfach ohne Probleme als programmieren akzeptieren würde, die dann aber irgendwie nie eine Programmiersprache angeguckt haben. Also die haben ihr Problem mit dem Werkzeug, was sie verstanden haben, gelöst. Und das ist für mich auch schon Programmieren. Das ist sehr wichtig, sowohl das Verständnis für den Computer zu wecken, als auch andere Werkzeuge zur Verfügung zu stellen, diese Probleme zu lösen.
Ich denke, es ist auch eine Art von Selbstermächtigung. Man kann natürlich unglaublich viel machen. Man kann jetzt heutzutage auf relativ einfache Art und Weise seine eigene Webseite machen. Man kann irgendwie seine eigenen Daten visualisieren, wenn man irgendwas verstehen will oder jemanden verständlich machen will. Man kann alle möglichen Skripte schreiben, um sich irgendwas klar zu machen oder mal was auszuprobieren oder so. Und das öffnet einem natürlich Welten. Und das ist, weil ich finde, dass es so eigentlich recht einfach zu lernen ist, ist es eine ganz tolle Sache, die einem Möglichkeiten eröffnet und die einem auch Reichweite gibt.
Wenn du guckst, was in deinem Zuhause heute an Aktoren reingeschraubt wird, die man ansteuern kann, du kannst dein Licht ansteuern. Du kannst deine Rollläden hoch und runter fahren lassen. Du kannst die Heizung steuern. Und für viele Menschen ist das auch so ein Weg dahin, weil die wollen das dann plötzlich, wie kriege ich eigentlich meine Hausautomation dahin, dass sie das tut und plötzlich setzen sie sich damit auseinander, wie das angesteuert wird und schreiben dann ihre ersten kleinen Programme und haben dann plötzlich, weil sie ein kleines Problem haben, was sie gelöst haben wollen, sich damit auseinandergesetzt und dann dieses Werkzeug durchdrucken und wenn man Glück hat, dann haben sie da genug Abstraktionsleistung mitgebracht und das auf andere Probleme auch zu übertragen. Und da ich davon ausgehe, dass so als gebildeter Mitteleuropäer man das Handwerkszeug mitbringt, also ich glaube, hier ist keiner zu blöd zum Programmieren.
Hat nichts mit Mitteleuropäer zu tun.
Genau. Deswegen denke ich, das kann einfach jeder und ich denke, dass jeder der Probleme grob runterbrechen kann, auch nur noch so ein bisschen das wirkliche Handwerkszeug braucht, das dann auch runterzuschreiben.
Also was mich jetzt gerade Frage ist, wir werden ja gleich noch über verschiedene Wege auch reden und wie man das anfangen kann, wie man Programmieren lernen kann. Ist es jetzt nur empfohlen, also das überhaupt, sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen, Programmieren zu lernen, zumindest Programmieren verstehen zu lernen, dass man das sozusagen nur überhaupt anfangen soll, wenn man dann auch was richtiges damit machen will, also meine Hausautomatationen umprogrammieren oder mein Auto, einen Spritzelektronik umprogrammieren oder ist es, haltet es auch für sinnvoll, dass man sagt, okay, ich gucke mir das mal an und lasse mir quasi die Grundlagen erklären und dann habe ich zumindest mal so einen Einblick gehabt. Ist das auch schon hilfreich oder ist das quasi verschwendete Zeit, wenn man sowas macht?
Voll, das ist super hilfreich. Ich glaube auch, dass es total, dass jede da seinen, ihren legitimen Einstieg, ich sage jetzt mal, zu Technik bekommt. Ja, weil das war für mich, glaube ich, eher so der Einstieg in Technik überhaupt. Und ich bin zum Programmieren so ein bisschen gekommen über Netzpolitik, weil ich eigentlich Soziologie und Politikwissenschaften studiert habe. Und dann, das war so die Brücke dahin. Man kann aber alle möglichen Brücken hinbekommen. Die Brücken können auch ganz kurz sein. Man kann auch sofort wieder zurücklaufen. Für mich ist, glaube ich, das größte, ja, Entschuldigung. Nee, sag du zuerst. Also ich glaube, es gibt halt so ganz viele Wege, die dahin führen. Es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Motivationen, die dahin führen. Und ich sehe eher so die größte Barriere in dem, okay, dass man überhaupt so einen Weg sieht. Dass man überhaupt weiß, es gibt einen Weg dahin, zum Programmieren lernen oder zum sich mit Technik mehr auseinandersetzen oder so.
Und ich wollte jetzt fragen, was war dein konkreter erster Schritt, Programmieren zu lernen?
Ich glaube tatsächlich der famose Rails Girls Beginners Workshop am Frauentag 2015, also am 8. März. Es war vielleicht der 7. März, ich sag nur immer gerne im Frauentag.
Was ist das Rails Girls?
Genau, Rails Girls ist eine Initiative, die von einer Finnin gestartet wurde, vor glaube ich drei, vier, fünf, sechs Jahren vielleicht. Und die hat gesagt, die hat irgendwie angefangen einfach einen Workshop anzubieten, nur für Frauen tatsächlich. Und an dem Workshop konnte man irgendwie einen Tag lang sich mit Rails beschäftigen und ohne jegliche Vorkenntnisse daran teilnehmen. Und das hat sich dann irgendwie relativ schnell über das Land, über den Kontinent, mittlerweile gibt es das in allen möglichen Kontinenten, in allen möglichen Städten, solche Initiativen, die eben immer mal wieder einen Workshop anbieten, vollkommen kostenlos für erwachsene Frauen, ohne Vorkenntnisse, um sich mal mit Rails zu beschäftigen. Und das ist dann so ein Tutorial, was sie durcharbeiten. Man kriegt Mentoren, also so Coaches zur Seite gestellt, die selber programmieren, meistens irgendwie das als Beruf machen. Und viele bleiben dabei. Für viele war das die einzige Beschäftigung damit. Bei mir war das der Einstieg.
Okay, und Rails, also wann immer ich heute einen Namen höre, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass es entweder eine Programmiersprache oder sozusagen eine Entwicklungsumgebung, das heißt, es ist eine bestimmte Sache, die extra dafür gemacht ist, mit einer bestimmten Programmiersprache zu arbeiten. Rails ist...
Ja, das habe ich lange auch nicht verstanden, was das eigentlich ist. Genau, Rails ist ein Framework. Und ich würde jetzt mal sagen, das baut sozusagen auf Ruby auf. Ruby ist eine Progeniersprache. Da sieht man immer diesen roten Diamanten, also wie Ruby, das ist so das Zeichen für Ruby. Und Rails baut sozusagen auf oder nimmt Ruby und liefert dir sozusagen eine ganze Menge schon mit, damit du eine Web-Applikation bauen kannst. Und damit du nicht bei Null anfängst, bietet dir Rails eben schon sehr viel.
Also ich versuche mal zusammenzufassen, es gibt Programmiersprachen, eine davon ist Ruby. Und es gibt Frameworks, das sind sozusagen Baukästen im Sinne von einer Software-Umgebung, die es erlaubt, eine Programmiersprache in einer bestimmten Art und Weise zu benutzen.
Ja, es gibt bestimmt noch andere...
Inklusive der Bibliotheken, die man dafür braucht, damit man nicht alles noch mal selber hinschreiben muss, haben sich andere schon für die grundlegenden Probleme wie Benutzer anzulegen und ein Konzept davon zu haben, wie in deiner Webseite welche Unterseiten wo liegen. Hat sich jemand Gedanken gemacht, das vorher schon implementiert und zusammengefügt zu einem Werkzeugkasten, der dir erlaubt, diese Programme, die auf Computern laufen, wieder in Webseiten machen.
Ich möchte eine Frage einschieben, aber mit der Bitte um kurze Antwort. Und zwar hast du gerade gesagt, das bringt schon Sachen mit, die ich verwenden kann. Wenn ich jetzt anfange zu programmieren, ist es dann sinnvoll, dass ich sage, ok einzelne Bausteine des Problems, die du jetzt nimmst, gibt es schon woanders oder soll ich dann fürs bessere Verständnis lieber doch alles selber programmieren?
Das kommt drauf an. Es kommt auf den Menschen an, wie der gebaut ist, ob er schnell Ergebnisse sehen möchte. So eine Webseite, die einem sofort Dinge schon vorbereitet. Man muss wenig tun. Versus ich möchte eigentlich nur, dass mal ein Kreis auf dem Bildschirm gezeichnet wird, hat für unterschiedliche Menschen unterschiedliche AHA-Effekte. Deswegen kann man das nicht...
Also es ist nicht automatisch so, wenn ich alles selber programmiere, verstehe ich es besser.
Nicht jeder will alles verstanden haben. Nicht jeder muss verstanden haben, wie man einen Kreis mathematisch berechnet auf dem Bildschirm und nicht jeder muss verstanden haben, wie die Datenbank-Programmierung funktioniert, um eine Web-Applikation zu schreiben.
Nana, wie war es bei dir? Was war bei dir das konkrete erste Erlebnis?
Ich bin da so reingerutscht wie so viele. Ich bin ja schon ein bisschen älter. Und ich hab irgendwie Anfang der 90er angefangen mit Linux. Das war so 1994, 1995.
Was heißt angefangen? Was ist dir installiert?
Es gab dann irgendwie dieses neue Betriebssystem und es war irgendwie alles offen und umsonst und es war total spannend damals. Und damals war es eben noch so archivistisch, dass man eben ganz viel selber machen musste und musste man lernen, Bash-Skripte, also Shell-Programmierung zu lernen. Das ist so eine slippery slope.
Linux-Bash-Skripte, Shell-Programmierung, Entschuldigung?
Ja, das war, keine Ahnung, das war damals so, oder?
Was heißt denn das? Was ist eine Shell-Programmierung und ein Bash-Skript?
Also so ein offenes Betriebssystem.
Dann lass mal Nana erklären.
Nana kann das schon erklären.
Nee, ja, also das ist halt, ich bin jetzt irgendwie bei, ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen, okay. Ja, also man kann eben, man hat so ein Terminal Fenster, man schreibt da Befehle rein in dieses Terminal Fenster und dann macht der Computer was für einen, ne?
Das sind dann Dinge, die man normalerweise mit der Maus klicken würde? Also normalerweise im Sinne von bei Windows oder Apple?
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen offener, ne? Man kann so ein bisschen mehr hinter die Kulissen gucken und man kann dann eben recht einfach irgendwie kleine Skripte schreiben, also Mini-Programme, die dann irgendwas für einen machen. Also Text durchsuchen nach irgendwas.
Aber hast du dir das dann selber beigebracht oder warst du auch bei einem Lehrgang?
Nee, ich hab mir das dann so mit Büchern, hat man das damals noch gemacht. Weil es gab ja noch kein Internet und wir hatten ja nichts.
Na, na, erzählt von Krieg. Damals haben wir noch Bücher gelesen. Okay, aber der Punkt noch nicht hinaus will, du hast dir quasi sozusagen, du hast dir etwas installiert und hast dann das Interesse gehabt, okay, ich möchte aber tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr verstehen und ein bisschen sozusagen in den Eingeweiten herumfummeln. Und hast ja dann angelesen, also selber angelesen und beigebracht, was man dafür braucht.
Genau. Und dann ging das irgendwie immer so weiter und so. Und dann hab ich wieder ein bisschen aufgehört. Dann hatte ich nämlich was studiert und...
Das kommt ja manchmal inzwischen.
Also ich hatte dann Physik studiert und dann muss man irgendwie notwendigerweise immer, ist das ganz nützlich, dann schreibt man sich auch irgendwelche Skripte, um irgendwas zu berechnen und dann will man irgendwas automatisieren, weil es irgendwie immer zu faul ist, um es selber zu machen und so. Und dann, ja und dann bin ich da einfach so drin hängegeben.
Also immer aus der Notwendigkeit heraus.
Bei mir war es immer so, ich bin ein sehr fauler Mensch und ich möchte auch immer schnell Ergebnisse haben. Also bei mir war es immer so, ich muss jetzt irgendwas machen und ich schreibe mir ein Skript ganz schnell. Und das habe ich eigentlich immer ganz gut durchgehalten.
Das finde ich auch schon nicht uninteressant. Ein Punkt, weil in meinem Kopf ist Programmieren immer noch was sehr schweres. Aber das sozusagen, dass man öfter in Motivation kommen kann und sagen kann, hey, ich lerne das, weil im Endeffekt ist das einfacher, als das Problem anders zu lösen. Finde ich auch sehr interessant.
Also der Einstieg ist vor allen Dingen, also möchte ich auch noch mal klar machen, der Einstieg ist tatsächlich so einfach auf so einem Level, wo ich das mache, dass man also sehr schnell Erfolgserlebnisse hat und dass man eben sich für alles Mögliche was schreiben kann. Ich könnte jetzt vielleicht noch mal ein kleines Beispiel bringen, wie schön das sein kann. Ganz klein? Ganz klein. Zum Beispiel, ich arbeite an der Schule und da haben wir ein Bienenprojekt, also wir haben Bienen und da gibt es einen Bienenstock. Und wir wollen natürlich gerne wissen, was machen die Bienen, wenn wir nicht zugucken? Und da kann man so eine kleine Kamera installieren, man kann ihnen ein kleines Skript schreiben, irgendwie was so regelmäßig Fotos oder Videos davon macht. Das kann man dann irgendwie sich anzeigen lassen, man kann die Temperatur messen, die Luftfeuchtigkeit und so weiter. Man kann alles möglich rausfinden und das ist alles nicht schwer zu machen. Aber man hat dann plötzlich Ergebnisse. Also man sieht irgendwie Sachen, die man halt eben sonst ohne Computer so nicht sehen würde.
Wobei das glaube ich schon wieder für jemanden, der gar nicht programmieren kann, eher schon wieder wie magisch anhört. Aha, da hängt eine Kamera an dem Bienenstock und dann programmier ich da irgendwas?
Es ist nicht so schwer, ich mach das mit einer siebten Klasse.
Das führt dann wahrscheinlich dazu, dass sich die Leute jetzt noch dober vorkommen. Nee, das ist wirklich nicht schwer. Ich versuche nicht zu sagen, dass wir diese Grenze überschreiten, dass man sagt, das ist wirklich nicht schwer, aber dass man das auch zu sagen an einem Beispiel vielleicht erzählen könnte. Aber gut, vielleicht schaffen wir das im späteren Verlauf. Ich möchte vor der Nachrichten auf jeden Fall auch noch von Erdgeist wissen. Dein erstes Programmiererlebnis. Also wie bist du dazu gekommen überhaupt?
Das war 1800 und...
Ihr müsst ja nicht die Jahreszahlen sagen. Ihr habt alle weiße, lange Bärte und...
Ja, es war noch zu DDR-Zeiten. Da stand im Computerkabinett dann so ein KC-87 rum. Das war so eine Box. Und wenn man die angemacht hat, da gab es einen Prompt. Also sprich, da blinkte so ein weißes Dreieck und hat einen aufgefordert, was einzugeben. Und wenn man da dann die richtigen Zeilen hingeschrieben hat, dann hat dieser Computer das getan, was man wollte. Und dann wie einfach so Print, Hello ausgeführt. Und dann stand da Hello und dann war, ah, platze gefreut. Da passiert, was der tut jetzt, ich kann ihm hintippern. Und der tut dann das, was ich sage. Und dann gab's dann so spielerisch, der kann noch mehr. Da kann man so den Dinge nach Schleife tun lassen, immer wieder, ne, zurückspringen. Und dann kann er sich stundenlang damit beschäftigen. Das ist eine Schleife. Eine Schleife? Du sagst dem Computer, er soll woanders weitermachen oder er soll wieder zurückspringen und das noch mal machen, was er gerade gemacht hat. Und dann kann man den Computer dazu bringen, einfach das, was ich ihm gerade aufgetragen hab, dann stundenlang zu machen. Und dann sitzt man daneben und freut sich. Da scrollt die ganze Zeit die Zeile durch, die man ihm eingegeben hat. Super, der tut, was man will. Das kann man sich heute nicht mehr vorstellen. So Kinder, die mit so Mobiltelefonen groß werden, für die ist der Effekt wahrscheinlich nie so nachvollziehbar. Aber...
Der weiß. Also liebe Kinderinnen und Kinder und andere Hörerinnen und Hörer, falls ihr auch ein erstes Programmiererlebnis habt, ruft gerne an unter 0331 70 97 110. Nachdem wir jetzt schon die quasi persönlichen Erfahrungen des Programmierbeginns uns näher angeschaut haben, werden wir gleich mal versuchen zu ergründen, wie man das heutzutage noch so machen könnte. Vor allem noch eine kleine Musik von Lukasch, der ein neues Album rausgebracht hat. Open Source Musik, wie er das heißt, Creative Commons Musik, die man sich also runterlade und weitergeben kann, weil sie so lizenziert ist. Das Album heißt Glitch und so ist auch der Titel, den wir jetzt hören.
Abwintern?
Abwintern.
Abwintern. Nicht so ne Art abgehen zum Winter.
Ja, das trifft schon ziemlich gut.
Fritz.
Morgen Abend lauschen wir der streitbaren Jungautorin Ronja von Rönne beim Vorlesen aus ihrem Debüt-Roman Wir kommen. Kommt ihr auch? Wer dabei sein will, einfach gut Fritz hören. Oder fritz.de slash Abwintern. Im Fräulein Fritz, morgen Abend bei einer exklusiven Lesung mit Ronja von Rönne.
Leute, die lesen sind einfach für mich Trebers.
Aber Leute, die nicht lesen, frieren dafür öfter.
Hey, lass mal alle zusammen abwintern.
Mit Johanna Tesma.
Der mexikanische Präsident Nieto hat ein Treffen mit US-Präsident Trump abgesagt. Das hat das Präsidialamt am Abend in Mexiko mitgeteilt. Grund seien Provokationen Trumps. Er hat den Nieto per Twitter nahegelegt, auf den Besuch zu verzichten, wenn Mexiko nicht für die geplante Grenzmauer zahlt. Trump hat inzwischen angekündigt, dass er die Mauer durch Strafzölle finanzieren will. Auf alle mexikanischen Waren soll ein Zoll von 20 Prozent erhoben werden. Der Bundestag hat den Bundeswehreinsatz im westafrikanischen Mali verlängert. Alle Fraktionen mit Ausnahme der Linken stimmten dafür, dass künftig bis zu 1000 deutsche Soldaten in Mali stationiert werden. Bisher waren es 650. Die UN-Mission gilt zurzeit als gefährlichster Einsatz der Bundeswehr. Auch die Ausbildungsmission im Nordirak wurde verlängert. Die britische Regierung hat das Parlament in London um Zustimmung für den EU-Austritt gebeten. Der zuständige Minister Davies legte einen entsprechenden Gesetzentwurf vor. Er hoffe, die Abgeordneten respektieren den Wunsch des britischen Volkes, sagte er. Nach einem Urteil des obersten Gerichts braucht die britische Regierung die Zustimmung des Parlaments, um bei der EU formal den Austritt einzuleiten. Im Auswärtigen Amt in Berlin-Mitte ist in einem Raum ein Teil der Decke eingestürzt. Dabei ist ein Mensch schwer verletzt worden. Nach Informationen des RBB passierte der Unfall in einem Saal, in dem Besuchergruppen empfangen werden. Im Auswärtigen Amt soll schon einmal eine Decke eingestürzt sein, allerdings in einem anderen Raum. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen im Berlin Schöneberg minus 2 Grad und in Kreuzberg minus 1 Grad, in Potsdam Rheinsberg und Lindenberg minus 2 Grad, in Cottbus minus 3 Grad. Am Abend und in der Nacht ist es locker bewölkt und es bleibt meist trocken. Nachts kann es auf bis zu minus 10 Grad abkühlen. Morgen früh ist es erst ziemlich neblig, später kommt aber auch mal die Sonne durch. Bei Temperaturen zwischen 0 und 3 Grad. Auf der A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Werder gibt es zwischen Dreieck Nutetal und Ferch an einer Nachtbaustelle bis 5 Uhr früh nur eine freie Spur. Und in Berlin fährt die U-Bahnlinie 6 bis Ende des Monats nicht zwischen den Bahnhöfen Wedding und Kurt-Schumacher-Platz. Stattdessen könnt ihr den Bus nehmen. Allen unterwegs, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und zum Chaosradio gehören auch die Nerdmoves, die sind geschrieben vom Chaos Computer Club und werden präsentiert von Johannes Tesma.
Wechsel an der Spitze der FCC. US-Präsident Trump hat den Netzneutralitätskritiker Ajit Pai zum Vorsitzenden der Regulierungsbehörde Federal Communications Commission berufen. Pai ist Gegner der Netzneutralitätsregeln, die sein Vorgänger Tom Wheeler gegen den Widerstand der Industrie durchgesetzt hatte. Laut Pai soll die Politik nur im Notfall eingreifen, denn Regulierungspolitik müsse sich an der Realität des Marktes orientieren. CITES-Behörde wird in München angesiedelt. Der Bund hat die Standortfrage seiner neuen Sicherheitsbehörde geklärt. Das deutsche Pendant zur US-amerikanischen NSA kommt nach München. Ziel der Behörde wird die Entschlüsselung der Online-Kommunikation von Cyberkriminellen und Terroristen sein. Sie soll forschen, entwickeln und die technische Expertise für die Sicherheitsbehörden übernehmen. Wirtschaftsministerin Ilse Aigner von der CSU begrüßte die Entscheidung, dass CITES nach München kommt, sei eine gute Nachricht. CITES sei in Bayern gut aufgehoben, weil es dort schon erhebliche Kompetenzen im Bereich der Informationstechnik und IT-Sicherheit gäbe. Chaos Computer Club im Visier der Geheimdienste. Die Bürgerrechtsorganisation Büro Jansen & Jansen berichtet, dass der niederländische Inlandsgeheimdienst AIVD versucht, Informanten anzuwerben, die deutsche Hacker-Spaces ausspionieren sollen. Eine betroffene Person sagte der Organisation, sie solle den Auftrag bekommen, die Hacker-Spaces des Chaos Computer Clubs zu besuchen und dem AIVD interner zu berichten. Eine Sprecherin des Geheimdienstes dementierte das gegenüber netzpolitik.org. Linus Neumann, Sprecher des Chaos Computer Clubs, sagte, die Quellen des Chaos Computer Clubs beim AIVD hätten schon im Voraus Warnungen ausgesprochen. Deswegen sei man nur mäßig überrascht. Der Chaos Computer Club freue sich aber, dass ein weiterer Versuch der Unterwanderung an den hohen moralischen Prinzipien der Community gescheitert sei.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt oder diesen Sound dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Maurice Geider immer sonntags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio oder jederzeit auf fritz.de Musikstreams Heute mit Markus Richter und den Chaoten vom Chaos Radio.
Herzlich willkommen zurück Erdgeist, Nana und Marie. Und wir sprechen heute über das Programmieren lernen. Wir haben die erste halbe Stunde damit zugebracht, A zu hören, woher die drei Gäste ihr Programmieren haben, also wie sie dem zum ersten Mal begegnet sind und vor allen Dingen, warum es eine gute Idee ist, dass sich vielleicht jeder damit mal beschäftigt. Und ich versuch es mal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen und hoffe, keine Widerspruch zu erregen, weil die Welt ist mit Computern durchdrungen. Diese werden programmiert und wenn man weiß, was das ist, verlieren sie ihren magischen Einfluss, sondern sind einfach nur noch Werkzeuge. So, jetzt würde ich von euch ja gerne wissen, nachdem wir heute übers Programmieren lernen, reden, wie man das macht. Und ich weiß gar nicht genau, womit man da am besten anfängt. Sollten wir mal darüber reden, welche Sprachen, es gibt ja verschiedene Programmiersprachen, man nimmt oder lieber wo man das macht?
Ihr müsstet mir jetzt antworten, weil ich weiß nicht, wo man das machen kann. Also, soll ich mal gleich anfangen? Ich in meiner reichlich bemessenden Freizeit arbeite ich bei den CODA-Doschos mit. Und CODA-Doschos sind so offene Programmiernachmittage für Kinder. Und zwar so in der Regel ab 5 bis 17 Jahre. Die sind völlig kostenlos. Das findet so alle 2 bis 3 Wochen statt. Man kann einfach vorbeikommen, wenn man ein Kind oder ein Jugendlicher ist und daran Interesse hat. Und da hat man dann Mentoren, die einem helfen, das zu basteln, was man gerne machen möchte. Und wir haben verschiedene Tutorials, die wir den Kindern zeigen. Und ja, wir können ihnen natürlich die ganzen Fragen beantworten. Und was auch besonders schön ist, ist, dass die jugendlichen Kinder sich selber gegenseitig vernetzen können und andere Leute kennenlernen können, die daran auch Interesse haben. Und genau, also es gibt in Berlin und in Potsdam gibt es mehrere Coda-Dojos. Da kann man einfach mal gucken auf codadojo.com, die Stadt raussuchen, wo man jetzt gerne besuchen möchte. Es gibt das Ganze auch in Köln, in Hannover, in Nürnberg, Coda-Dojosar gibt es auch. Und genau, das wäre eine Möglichkeit, wenn man ein Kind oder ein Jugendlicher ist.
Es gibt noch Webseiten, die einem da in die Hand nehmen. Bevor man weiß, welche Programmiersprache man eigentlich benutzen möchte, sollte man erst wissen, was man eigentlich damit machen möchte. Es gibt ja die Möglichkeit, so kleine Prozessoren auf kleinen Boards zu programmieren, die da jetzt allenthalben rumgereicht werden, die günstig sind, wo man Aktoren dabei hat, die blinken.
Du hast jetzt schon Aktoren gesagt, sag nochmal genau was das ist.
Ein Aktor ist einfach irgendwas, was eine Aktion auslöst. Entweder Licht an oder ausmacht, also ein blinkt oder was Töne macht oder was Motoren antreibt oder vielleicht ein Ventil auf und zu macht. Das ist einfach ein Aktor, das Gegenteil von Sensor.
Sensor ist sozusagen, ich stelle fest, was passiert und Aktor ist, ich löse etwas aus.
Genau. Ganz häufig ist das Einfachste, was man so beim Programmieren machen kann, was auch sofort ziemlich einen Glücksrausch erfüllt ist. So ein Sensor mit wenig Aufwand mit dem Aktor verbinden. Wenn da irgendwas passiert, wenn ich mal den Knopf gedrückt habe, dann soll dieser kleine Computer mal Licht anmachen. Das ist so ein klassisches, also Licht anmachen im Sinne von diese LED da blinken lassen.
Das ist eigentlich immer ganz toll, wenn man irgendeinen Knopf drückt oder irgendwas hinschreibt und dann passiert was. Das ist, glaube ich, universell, dass das wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht.
Okay, jetzt hast du gesagt, man soll sich das was man lernt danach aussuchen, was man dann später mit erreichen will. Was ich mich da frage ist, also ich kann noch gar nicht programmieren und ich sage mir, ich möchte später irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einen Feuchtigkeitssensor für meinen Bad bauen, damit das Fenster automatisch aufgeht, wenn es nicht anfängt zu schimmeln. Und jetzt frage ich mich aber, soll ich dann wirklich genau das, also was auch immer, dann die Programmiersprache ist, die man für ein Smart Home irgendwie lernen muss, ist es sinnvoll, wirklich dann da hinzugehen, sagen, weil ich das will, lerne ich jetzt diese Sprache? Oder ist es vielleicht auch sinnvoll, erst zu gucken und zu sagen, okay, es gibt vielleicht Sprachen oder Dinge, die besonders gut zum Lernen geeignet sind. Ist es sinnvoller, damit anzufahren?
Da fragst du, glaube ich, bei mir den falschen, weil ich würde, da würde ich das einfach mal abgeben, die Frage.
Ich denke, es gibt verschiedene Scriptsprachen, die besonders gut geeignet sind, um sie zu lernen und mit denen man dann auch sehr, sehr viel machen kann. Also Python ist da ein sehr gutes Beispiel. Das ist eine Scriptsprache, die man verwenden kann für Web-Programmierungen. Man kann Texte damit durchsuchen. Man kann alles Mögliche damit machen. Ist auch sehr weit verbreitet. Es gibt tatsächlich Menschen, die damit Geld verdienen, dass sie Python-Programme schreiben. Also das ist so, würde ich sagen, so eine ideale Einsteigersprache. Ist sehr einfach zu lernen, ja. Es geht nicht zu sehr ins Detail. Es ist nicht zu hardwarener und eben sehr vielseitig verwendbar.
Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel sehr gut vorstellen, dass man, wenn man eben genau das, wie du jetzt beschrieben hast mit dem Bart, irgendwas ganz Bestimmtes hast du damit vor, dass du dir dann genau anschaust, was du dafür brauchst, um dahin zu kommen. Und das mag da nicht das Leichteste sein für viele andere. Aber für dich ist es gerade einfach genau das, was du brauchst, um dahin zu kommen, was du eigentlich haben möchtest, um dein Resultat zu bekommen. Und dann merkst du vielleicht auf dem Weg, hey, ich würde da ja gerne noch irgendwie A, B und C verstehen. Das brauch ich jetzt gerade nicht. Das schieb ich mal irgendwie auf. Und dann entwickelt sich da vielleicht einfach auch noch mehr dabei. Oder du merkst halt, okay, wie eine neue Sprache lernen, um jetzt hier diesen einen Satz zu sagen oder um diesen Artikel zu schreiben, brauch ich vielleicht doch ein bisschen Grammatik oder brauch noch ein bisschen, muss noch ein bisschen ein paar Mehrwörter lernen, damit ich daraus auch auswählen kann. Und es kann aber genauso gut auch sein, dass dir eben jemand sagt, hey, wie in meinem Falle, lerne doch Rails bzw. Ruby dann in dem Fall, also die Programmiersprache Ruby. Dann habe ich das einfach gemacht, weil es da eine sehr vitale Community in Berlin dazu gibt. Und tatsächlich auch speziell ganz viele Frauen gibt, die sich wöchentlich in so Study Groups treffen. Und dann dachte ich halt eher, das sind sympathische Menschen und ich habe Bock mit denen zusammen zu lernen.
Also kann man vielleicht sagen, es gibt verschiedene Ansätze auch für das Programmieren. Also es gibt dieses, ich möchte jetzt dieses eine Problem lösen, dann gehe ich mit dem Kopf durch die Wand und das tut vielleicht ein bisschen weh, aber letztlich habe ich das Problem geklärt. Man kann sich tatsächlich gucken, es gibt bestimmte Sprachen, die einfach sind. Und es gibt aber tatsächlich auch die Idee, dass man sagt, es gibt vielleicht eine Community und mir ist es dann erst mal egaler, welches Ziel ich damit umsetzen kann. Ich mach das erstmal, wo ich es leicht lernen kann.
Ich habe noch eine Idee, was ja neuerdings weit verbreitet ist, dass du auf deinem Computer inzwischen schon immer, ohne dass du dir noch was installieren musst, schon eigentlich einen Interpreter für so eine Programmiersprache, nämlich JavaScript, dabei hast. Und in jeder Webseite oder quasi jeder Webseite, die du heute abrufst, sind so auch kleine Schnipselchen JavaScript dabei. Und wenn du nur so zwei, drei Menüpunkte in deinem Browser klickst, dann kannst du dir erstens anzeigen lassen, was dieses JavaScript auf der Seite tut. Und du kannst da Knöpfe drücken und Zahlen verändern und ein bisschen mal schauen, wie die das machen. Und du hast mit ziemlich geringer Hürde erst mal eine grobe Vorstellung, wie diese Webseite funktioniert, die dir da angezeigt wird. Und da brauchst du dann nicht mal jemand, der dir hilft, sondern du kannst einfach aus Interesse mal reingucken. Vielleicht findest du Wörter wieder, die auf der Webseite angezeigt werden. Und du kannst Dinge verändern und schauen, ob es noch funktioniert. Wenn nicht, wieder rückgängig machen. Das ist so ungefähr, wie ich damals angefangen habe, auch einfach so irgendwas nehmen, was es schon gab und dann verändern und schauen, was dann passiert.
Klassische ängstliche Frage in so einem Moment kommt ist, kann ich da was kaputt machen, was mir weh tut?
Nö, normalerweise nicht.
Okay, also das Schlimmste, was wir sehen können ist, die Webseite funktioniert nicht mehr, dann lade ich sie einfach neu und dann...
Genau. Und du musst nicht mal was runterladen auf dein Computer, sondern das kommt schon eigentlich mit deinem Betriebssystem mit.
Ich hätte einen kleinen Einspruch. Ich mache zwar auch total gerne Sachen kaputt und dann wieder heil. Und ich kann das total gut verstehen, diese Leidenschaft, die Erdgeister beschreibt. Ich denke, es gibt heutzutage wirklich sehr viele, sehr gute Einsteigertutorials, wo man erst mal gucken kann, wie geht denn das überhaupt und wie schreibe ich jetzt erst mal den einen Befehl und dann vielleicht die nächste Zeile noch mal einen anderen Befehl oder so. Dass man sozusagen erst mal so ein Level 0 irgendwie sich erst mal präsentieren lässt von einem Buch oder einem Tutorial oder von einer Webseite, wo es tatsächlich darum geht, das zu lernen. Und danach kann man immer noch diesen sehr kreativen Weg einschlagen.
Ich hätte einen Kompromissvorschlag. Ich finde, was Erdgas gesagt hat, ich kann sofort anfangen und ich brauche nichts, weil das ist schon bei mir, das finde ich unspannend. Vielleicht könnte man sagen, das kann man ausprobieren. Ich habe auch gerade gedacht, ich mache das manchmal mit dem Quelltext an der Webseite anzeigen lassen. Das ist schon auch echt viel und echt, also wenn man gar keine Ahnung hat, glaube ich wirklich kompliziert. Man kann das ja machen, reingucken, weil man dann feststellt, doch zu viel, also die Wand ist doch noch zu dick, dann sozusagen zu einem irgendwie Tutorial gehen und gucken, ob man da vielleicht mehr lernt. Ich versuche ja mit verschiedenen Dingen zusammenzuhören. Ich habe tatsächlich sozusagen, ich überlege gerade, ich hatte tatsächlich auch mal so einen Moment, es gibt ein Spiel Cookie-Clicker heißt das. Das ist total doof, weil alles was man da macht, ist man klickt am Anfang 20 mal, glaube ich, und dann läuft das Spiel von alleine. Indem es halt auf der Webseite Zahlen hochzählt und wenn man dann, also man sammelt Kekse, und wenn man je mehr Kekse man hat, desto schneller klickt sich das selber. Also es ist wirklich total albern. Aber es gibt auch in dem Spiel eine Auszeichnung dafür, wenn man in dem Code rumschreibt, tatsächlich kann man sich irgendwo einfach die Anzahl der eigenen Kekse erhöhen. Und das sozusagen kann vielleicht tatsächlich so ein Einstieg sein.
Alter, du hast programmiert. Markus!
Genau. Ich möchte jetzt erst mal, dass wir uns das später merken, aber ich will noch übersprechen über die Hürde, also die Schwierigkeit vom Einstieg weiterzukommen. Aber ich will noch mal zurückkehren zu den Programmiersprachen. Ihr habt jetzt eine genannt, Python. Und Ruby, stimmt. Na ja.
Und JavaScript?
Ihr habt keine Insider-Gags, die wir noch nicht verstehen, bitte. Also wir haben zwar schon drei Programmiersprachen erwähnt, aber erst mal einer gesagt, warum die Programmiersprache? Bei JavaScript liegt es ja nicht daran, ob die jetzt gut oder schlecht ist, sondern die ist halt einfach da, deswegen kann man damit rummachen. Aber so dieses Pysen, das kann ich lernen. Gibt es denn dann noch was? Ich meine, es gibt ja eine Unzahl von Programmiersprachen.
Wenn du aus der Windows Welt kommst, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich als erstes mit diesem Visual Basic konfrontiert werden, was Microsoft sich irgendwie ausgedacht hat und auch er möchte, dass sie dich dann in ihr Ökosystem reinziehen.
Das hängt an den Office-Sachen hinten dran, ne? Also das ist ja so, bei Office kann man sozusagen, man kann Office einfach benutzen, dann kann man sich sozusagen Makros, also kurze Befehle schreiben und wenn man das noch eine Spur komplexer macht, dann ist das schon Visual Basic, ne?
Man kann auch ganz anders anfangen. Man kann, wenn man das, meistens Kinder fangen so an, dass sie Scratch anfangen. Ein Kollege von mir hat mal gesagt, man darf den Kindern nicht Scratch beibringen, weil das ist wie Track. Was ist das? Da kommen die nie wieder von runter. Das ist so eine grafische Programmiersprache in Anführungszeichen. Das ist so wie ein bisschen Lego. Man hat bestimmte Elemente, die kann man zusammenklicken. Die gehen auch nur richtig zusammen. Wenn man sie falsch klickt, dann passen sie nicht zusammen. Da kann man bestimmte Schleifen, Abläufe, Bedingungen usw. Also Sachen, die es auch in den richtigen Programmen gibt, kann man da grafisch zusammenklicken und dann passiert was. Das Schöne daran ist, dass man innerhalb von 2-3 Minuten ein kleines Spiel programmieren kann. Da bewegt sich was auf dem Bildschirm. Das ist meistens so eine kleine Katze. Das ist eben sehr sehr leichter Einstieg. Meistens für Kinder, aber auch ältere Menschen können das auch machen.
Ihr habt ja bei Python dazu gesagt, dass eine Programmiensprache die machen Leute auch um Geld zu verdienen. Das heißt, ich vermute, man kann mit Python auch ernsthaft Dinge anstellen.
Das ist wirklich sowas zum Lernen. Das ist auch der Sinn der Sache, das von MIT entwickelt. Es läuft auch mit Flash. Es ist nicht besonders toll für einen richtigen Programmierer. Das führt nicht weiter. Da muss man irgendwann den Sprung machen, aber ich will doch damit was Vernünftiges machen. Dann ist der nächste Schritt, was wir unseren Kindern immer sagen, ist Python.
Eine Art und Weise hat ein Kumpel von mir seine Kinder über Minecraft angefixt. Das ist so ein... Da könnte man es mit einem Computerspiel verwechseln. Du läufst mit einem Männchen durch die Gegend, versuchst deine Welt aufzubauen, irgendwie nicht zu verhungern, Tiere zu halten, all sowas. Und das ist ziemlich abstrakt gehalten. Aber wenn man sich da erstmal in der Welt zurechtgefunden hat, dann kann man plötzlich Abläufe skripten. Dann kann man in der einen oder anderen Programmiersprache, ich glaube JavaScript ist standardmäßig die Sprache dafür, kann man dann in dieser Welt auch wirklich, das ist dann schon Aktoren in einer virtuellen 3D-Welt, aber eine, die den Leuten, die sich da ihre kleine Welt gebaut haben, schon sehr wichtig ist.
Aber ist das Teil der Spielüberfläche oder macht man das quasi außerhalb des Spiels und geht dann ins Spiel rein und kann dann sozusagen die programmierten Teile benutzen?
Man kann das wirklich live machen. Man kann ein Fensterchen irgendwie mit seinem Skript machen und auf dem anderen Fensterchen hat man dann das Spiel offen und dann kann man da irgendwie, weiß ich, Riesen-TNT-Blöcke bauen oder Vulkane oder Überschreibungen.
Aber das ist halt nicht Teil des Spiels. Minecraft ist ja dieses, ich habe ein 3D-Spiel quasi, also in der Ego-Perspektive und laufe da rum und kann so blöckchenweise diese Welt verändern.
Man kann Minecraft auch ohne Programmieren spielen. Aber es gibt eben diese Möglichkeit, dass ich da drinnen auch Sachen skripte.
Aber das machst du nicht in dem Spiel drin, sondern das machst du quasi außerhalb des Spiels auf deinem Computer in einem extra Fenster.
Schon, aber die Immersion ist dann schon da.
Es passiert sofort. Auch in dem Spiel warst du gerade nicht.
Das Feedback ist sofort.
Ja, es passiert sofort. Aber was ich sozusagen, also das Ding ist, wenn es in dem Spiel wäre, dann hätte man ja in der Spielwelt etwas, wo man hingehen würde, oder man könnte sozusagen ohne diese Welt ganz zu verlassen, könnte man ein Fenster, wo man Sachen reinschreibt, aber man benutzt sozusagen einen anderen Teil des Haupteins.
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen mühsam, wenn du das mit diesem Zauberstab innerhalb des Spiels machst. Aber die Geschichte geht noch weiter, die ich erzählen wollte. Dass inzwischen auch KI-Forscher, Freunde von mir, einfach in der Minecraft-Welt programmieren, weil sie meinen, für die Fragen, die so künstliche Intelligenz gerade lösen möchte, ist es ja schon prima, da mal so eine Welt, die man zwar auch algorithmisch und vom Computer erfassen lassen kann, aber die irgendwie noch mächtig genug ist, als dass die künstliche Intelligenz da drin reagieren muss, damit das Männchen nicht totgeht. Und so von dem kleinsten, ich skripte mir ein paar Steinchen zurecht, bis irgendwie, ich hab da bleeding edge künstliche Intelligenz.
Aber die künstliche Intelligenz, die steuert an die Spielfigur?
Ist das auch ein schönes Spielfeld, was eben nicht nur für Kids ist, sondern am Ende auch am aktuellen Stand der Forschung mit als Werkzeug dient?
Da sind aber schon noch ein paar Ebenen dazwischen. Aber wenn ich das noch versuche zusammenzubringen, das ist so ähnlich wie Nana, die erzählt hat, ich habe Linux, und wollte dann dahinter gucken und das verändern, und habe deswegen Befehle gelernt, ich habe Minecraft, und will jetzt mal dahinter gucken und kann das verändern und lerne deswegen so ein paar Befehle. Ich habe jetzt noch eine Frage, die nur am Rande mit dem zu tun hat, was wir gerade besprochen haben, aber die ich glaube manche Leute stellen, und zwar, es gibt ja JavaScript und es gibt Java. Da hängen sich zwei Fragen auf. A, dieses Java hört man an allen Ecken und Enden, wo auch alle sagen, das ist ganz toll und so, ist das was, was ich lerne? Und, ist JavaScript und Java dasselbe?
Nein.
Warum heißen die dann so? Da muss ich passen. Ich weiß nur, dass Java sozusagen eigentlich der Standard auch noch in der Informatik heute ist. Dass sozusagen alle Informatik-Studierende mal durch die Java-Schule gehen.
Und ist das eher so eine Art Bootcamp? Ihr müsst euch alle mal dreckig machen und es muss wehtun? Oder ist das sozusagen was Sinnvolles, um Programmieren zu lernen?
Das kommt auf die Uni an. Einige Universitäten wollen, dass du was Richtiges lernst. Andere Universitäten wollen, dass du was Nützliches lernst. Java ist, wenn du da draußen in der Industrie irgendwie angestellt werden möchtest, dann ist es ganz gut, Java zu können, weil da ziemlich viel Fleißarbeit schon in fertigen Bibliotheken und Programmfragmenten drinsteckt. Ich glaube aber, dass langsam Java auch abgelöst wird von Python. Und JavaScript ist irgendwann... Nein, die haben nichts miteinander zu tun. Sind irgendwie früher mal beide im Browser ausgeführt worden, als Java noch standardmäßig im Browser mitkam. Aber JavaScript ist selber eine Sprache, die üblich dazu benutzt wurde, um in diesem Baum, der deine Webseite beschreibt, ein bisschen kompliziert, aber um darin Manipulationen vorzunehmen, dass die Webseite dann anders aussieht, wenn der Benutzer irgendwas tut. Und da musst du ein bisschen Programmlogik mitliefern und das wurde dann ursprünglich in JavaScript spezifiziert, dass man das so macht.
Warum die gleich heißen? Um die Leute zu verwirren.
War vielleicht gerade modern zu der Zeit.
Hey, lass uns irgendwas mit Java machen. Na gut, dann sind das jetzt alle Programmiersprachen. Wissen wir jetzt das Wichtigste? Nein. Was fehlt denn noch?
Ich wollte auch noch... Ähm, nee, wegen der Sprachen irgendwie. Ich hab mich entschlossen, ich guck jetzt niemanden an. Ich hab mich entschlossen, Anfang dieses Jahres C zu lernen. Jemand auch einen Aufruf, mich dabei zu begleiten, wenn er Lust hat. Ähm, und ich, also im Sinne von, es gibt sehr viele Sprachen. Ich kenn auch andere Leute, die irgendwelche Maschinensprachen lernen. Ähm, und da irgendwie ihre eigene Motivation mitbringen, die sehr hoch ist. Und andere Leute, die auf dem Weg sagen, dass sie das auf keinen Fall machen, das macht keinen Sinn. Und ich lern lieber was ganz anderes. Und tatsächlich, würde ich sagen, kommt es dann gar nicht so sehr darauf an, welche Sprache du jetzt, oder wem du jetzt vertraust, welche Sprache da am besten ist. Sondern wenn du wirklich erst mal gar keinen Plan hast oder gar kein festes Ziel vor Augen hast, dann einfach das, was dir gerade in den Sinn kommt und wo du denkst, dass darauf hast du Lust, einfach ausprobieren.
Das ist ja eigentlich immer ein guter Rat. Ich muss aber eine Verständnisfrage stellen. Was ist eine Maschinensprache?
Du kannst eben beliebig nah an den Prozessor rangehen, wenn du so willst. Jeder weiß praktisch, dass es irgendwas mit Nullen und Einsen zu tun hat. Und wenn du dann einen Schritt von den Nullen und Einsen weggehst, dann bist du vielleicht bei Assembler. Das ist dann so ein bisschen einfacher zu verstehen. Da musst du nicht mehr die ganzen Nullen und Einsen schreiben. Nur dann kannst du Wörter schreiben oder Zahlen. Und dann kannst du sozusagen immer weiter aufbauen und kannst es dir immer einfacher machen. Eine Sprache nimmt dir dann Sachen ab. Das heißt, es gibt Libraries, so Bibliotheken, wo schon mal jemand was programmiert hat. Das kannst du einfach weiterverwenden. Und es gibt auch so einen gewissen Abstand vom Prozessor, wo du sagen kannst, ich will mich jetzt aber nicht kümmern, in welches Register das geschrieben wird und wie das was zuerst berechnet wird. Das soll jemand für mich machen. Und das macht dann in der Regel der Compiler.
Also ich erspare jetzt mal zu fragen, was ist ein Register? Das weiß ich auch nicht so genau. Ich wollte nur mal zusammen... Also es gibt so einen Komplexitätsstrahl. Und auf der einen Seite ist, es werden ganz konkrete Nullen und Einsen hin und her geschubst. Und auf der anderen Seite ist Scratch. Ich klicke mir bunte Dinger zusammen, die irgendwie Sachen machen.
Ja, das gibt es aber auch für so... Ich nenne sie mal Schlibsträger. Also für... Wie sagt man denn politisch korrekt dazu? Für Entscheider. Da hat auch jemand mal sich gedacht, Mann, das mit dem Hinschreiben ist ja ein bisschen kompliziert. Und hat dann irgendwie so UML entworfen, wo du auch nur noch diese Abflussdiagramme dann einfach so mit der Maus hinmalst und dann diese Pfeile dazwischen ziehst, das du benennst und die Abhängigkeiten so beschreibst. Oder wenn du heutzutage ein Programm für ein iPhone schreibst, da ist in dieser Programmierumgebung für alle Abläufe, die nicht wirklich Funktionalität sind, sondern einfach nur, wie man zwischen den Fenstern hin und her kommt und wo ist jetzt eine Tabelle und wo kommt welche Hierarchie-Ebene hin. Das kann man auch inzwischen alles mit der Maus klicken. Da muss man nicht programmieren im Sinne von, was du von meintest, Text hinschreiben, sondern da muss man einfach nur sagen, ich ziehe hier mal mein Fenster auf und ziehe da eine Tabelle rein. Und dann wird, wenn man da draufklickt, wird das per Mausklick mit einem anderen Fenster verbunden. Das geht dann auf, wenn man sich das aussucht und so. Und das ist auch eine ziemlich einfache Art und Weise, der Leute erst mal rein zu locken. Das ist mit dem Programmieren gar nicht so kompliziert.
Das dachte ich die ganze Zeit. Ich würde mich wirklich noch interessieren, ob da draußen sagen Leute, die diese Erfahrungen gemacht haben. 0331 70 97 100. Wir machen eine kleine Pause hier im Chaosradio und sind gleich wieder da. Doomsday von Lukasch hier im Chaosradio in Blumenz, an dem ich recht herzlich zurückbegrüße Marie, Nana und Erdgeist. Hallo! Und es geht heute ums Programmieren, Lernen. Wir haben schon ein bisschen darüber geredet, warum und mit was. Und da wurde schon über verschiedene Programmiersprachen gesprochen, die es so gibt. Und jetzt haben wir per Studiomessage ein paar Nachrichten reinbekommen. Unter anderem möchte jemand wissen, ob ihr wisst, was der Java-Hamster ist. Was ist der Java-Hamster?
Der Java-Hamster ist ein Tutorial, mit dem man Java lernen kann. Es ist ein Tutorial, ich suche immer noch nach einem total super einfachen Java-Tutorial. Wenn jetzt jemand noch einen Tipp hat, außer dem Java-Hamster, bin ich total glücklich. Ich sehe die Vorteile des Java-Hamsters, aber ich denke, es kann vielleicht noch besser gehen.
Was sind denn die Vorteile des Java-Hamsters?
Es ist ein Einstieg in die Programmiersprache Java und man hat einen Hamster und man kann so eine Art Labyrinth bauen und den Java-Hamster irgendwie, ich glaube, Körner fressen lassen. Ich habe das letzte Mal irgendwie im Sommer angeguckt. Genau, das ist wie gesagt, man kann damit Java lernen, so ein bisschen die Grundlagen. Wie gesagt, ich dachte, vielleicht geht es noch ein bisschen bunter oder so.
Julio hat uns das geschrieben, man meinte, der Java-Hamster kann mittlerweile auch Python und Ruby. Das ist auch noch eine Frage, es gibt ja verschiedene Programmiersprachen und hier hätte man ja ein Beispiel, da könnte man sich ein Problem in verschiedenen Programmiersprachen gleich angucken. Jetzt frage ich mich auch gerade, ist es eh so, wenn man Programmieren anfängt, dass man eigentlich nicht eine Programmiersprache lernt, sondern wenn man eine gelernt hat, dann weiß man auch, man kann auch noch eine lernen. Dass es eigentlich sinnvoll ist, das parallel zu machen. Also nicht parallel, aber sich gleich von Anfang an darauf einzustellen, wenn ich das ernsthaft verfolgen will. Also nicht nur, wenn es mir nur um grundsätzliches Verständnis geht, sondern wenn ich es ernsthaft verfolgen will, muss ich eh damit rechnen, dass ich verschiedene Sprachen lerne?
Also man kann auch so enden wie ich und kann irgendwie 20 Sprachen so richtig schlecht am Ende. Nichts richtig. Das ist aber auch kein Hindernis. Also ich bin immer auch dafür, dass man sagen kann, ich hauptsache es funktioniert und es kommt was bei raus und ich habe ein Problem dann gelöst damit. Aber ja, es macht wahrscheinlich irgendwann, wenn man es ernsthaft betreiben will, Sinn, dass man sich irgendwie spezialisiert.
Aber ist jede Sprache sozusagen ganz was Neues? Oder ist es auch so quasi, man spricht Deutsch und kann dann Berlinern umwechseln?
Na, es ist ein bisschen so auch generell wie bei den Menschen so, wenn ich jetzt Deutsch Muttersprachlerin bin, dann fällt mir Englisch und Holländisch wahrscheinlich nicht so schwer.
Aber Finnisch, aber Finnisch.
Aber Finnisch, genau. Und dann wiederum irgendwie Hochchinesisch oder Ungarisch, ja, ist für mich total schwierig. Aber erst mal dieses Konzept zu wissen, meine Muttersprache ist eine Sprache unter vielen. Das ist glaube ich schon der Einstieg dazu, dass du überhaupt verstehst, okay, es gibt sowas wie Grammatik und es macht Sinn, sich Sprache irgendwie systematisch anzueignen. So ein Syntax.
Nee, Syntax ist das, welche Wörter es gibt und Grammatik ist in welcher Reihenfolge die Wörter erscheinen müssen, damit es valides Stück Programmcode ist.
Ich denke es gibt, vielleicht sollte man das mal in so einer Einsteigersendung auch sagen. Dass es so verschiedene Konzepte gibt. Ich glaube, so zwei große ist eben mal das objektorientierte und dann das Funktionale. Ich glaube, du kannst dazu was sagen. Erdgeist, mehr als ich auf jeden Fall.
Das eine ist irgendwie so eher imperativ, dass man hinschreibt, mach mal jetzt das und dann mach das und dann mach das. Und das andere ist so eher funktional, dass man sagt, ich hätte gerne am Ende dieses Problem gelöst. Computer, mach mal bitte das äh...
Nee, ein bisschen weniger abstrakt mal kurz.
Möchtest du hierher kommen, machst das hervorragend.
Echt schwierig, weil dieser zweite funktionale Programmieren kommt sehr krass aus der Mathematik. Deswegen, da könnte man noch mal eine eigene Sendung dazu machen. Ich glaube, das kann ich nicht kurz unterbrechen.
Ich muss ganz kurz sagen, weil ich habe Freunde, Jugendliche, die sind mir böse, wenn ich jetzt hier über Java spreche und nicht Haskell erwiene.
Okay, ne, stopp halt. Muss ich dich jetzt leider unterbrechen, weil wir gerade jetzt bei der Mathematik, da passt eine Hörerfrage, die wir per Studie-Message bekommen haben. Und zwar fragt Stefan, er hätte mal ein Buch von Norbert Wiener gelesen, anscheinend eine große Nummer irgendwie bei den Informatikern. Und er fragt jetzt, ist das mit dem Programmieren mittlerweile, also er hat das nicht so geschrieben, ich lese das heraus als die Frage, zu so einer Art Handwerkskunstverkommen? Oder hängt da auch noch sozusagen das Interesse an den höheren mathematischen Problemen, die dahinterstecken drin? Oder kann man beides machen?
Man kann Informatik machen, ohne eine Zeile zu programmieren, jemals. Also Informatik ist eine eigene Wissenschaft. Ich glaube, Norbert Wiener, das war so was in Richtung Kybernetik, irgendwie sozusagen noch bevor es Informatik gab als Begriff. Das ist eine Wissenschaft für sich. Das hat auch alles seine Berechtigung und so. Aber es muss nicht mit Programmieren einhergehen, sag ich jetzt mal so. Man kann wiederum auch programmieren, ohne auch nur die blasseste Ahnung von Informatik zu haben, bis zu einem gewissen Punkt.
Das stimmt, sehr schmerzhaft. Das merkt man auch an den Universitäten, dass dort Leute anfangen, Informatik zu studieren, die eigentlich programmieren, für ihren Beruf lernen wollen. Die wollen dann eigentlich später mal Java können, damit sie eben bei Siemens oder einer großen Firma anfangen können, irgendwo so 9 to 5 Module für irgendeine Wirtschaftsanwendung da durchzuimplementieren. Die sind eigentlich in Informatik falsch aufgehoben. Die sollten an die Fachhochschule gehen und dann Systemintegration oder halt programmieren lernen. Aber weil einfach so viele Leute bei der Informatik angerannt gekommen sind und es dann Kritik gab, dass die da Regen stehen gelassen wurden, haben sich dann auch in der Informatik in vielen Universitäten dann die Professoren dazu entschlossen, auch dort Java beizubringen.
Also ist quasi Informatik an der Uni mittlerweile sowas wie Jura, wo man sagt, das ist eigentlich eine Ausbildung und das wissenschaftliche Gerät doch ab und zu den Hintergrund?
Es gibt übrigens, möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz sagen, man muss kein Abi haben. Man kann auch zum Beispiel Ausbildung machen als Anwendungsprogrammierer. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie keinen Bock hat, Abi zu machen, es gibt auch andere Wege, Programmierer zu werden.
Ja, oder man geht zu den Rails Girls Beginners Worker. Da muss man gar nichts können.
Wir sprechen in der letzten halben Stunde noch, also ab halb zwölf nochmal genau, was es für verschiedene Programme gibt, wo man hingehen kann oder wie man das machen kann. Nicht Programme, die man programmiert, sondern Programme im Sinne von Veranstaltungen, die Programmieren, Lernen ermöglichen.
Ich würde total gerne auf deine Frage wieder zurückkommen.
Welche?
Was du bestimmt magst, mit dem sich wissenschaftlich damit auseinandersetzen. Weil es gab ja in letzter Zeit diverse Meldungen, dass gerade kritische Infrastruktur von Hackern übernommen worden ist. Und das lag daran, dass die Programmiersprache, die da benutzt worden ist, auch sehr hemmsärmlich daher kam und damals eigentlich eher so schnell Dinge erledigen sollte und wenig Augenmerk auf formale Korrektheit gelegt worden ist. Das heißt, da hat man schnell was hingeschrieben und hat die ganzen Randbedingungen ignoriert. Wird schon keiner irgendwie mal umlauter eingeben, geht schon alles. Und das macht vielleicht auf so einer Webseite, die Nachrichten ausliefert, weniger Probleme als irgendwie vielleicht wenn du eine Steuerung für dein Auto hast, wo das Bremssystem gesteuert werden soll. Da willst du eigentlich schon, dass am besten auch noch eine Art von Hardcore-Mathematikern durchbewiesen ist, dass diese Funktion tut genau das, was ich dort in meinen festen Bedingungen vorher und nachher festgelegt habe. Wenn es es nicht tut, dann ist da ein Fehler drin und das muss durchgetestet und am Ende am besten auch durch bewiesen werden. Und das kann man in einigen Programmiersprachen quasi nicht machen und in anderen Programmiersprachen die sind extra dafür angelegt worden, dass das geht. Und das sind so funktionale Programmiersprachen, weil das eben an der Mathematik stark orientiert ist und sehr formal, also die Grammatik ist sehr fest. Das heißt also, was so ein valides Programm ist, ist so wie sehr strikten Regeln unterworfen. Und damit lässt sich das am Ende auch von einem Computer beweisen, dass die tut, was sie soll. Das also gibt diverse Anwendungsbereiche in der jetzt moderne Informatik, wo wieder viel Augenmerk auf Sicherheit gelegt wird. Bekommt das wieder echt neuen Aufschwung, nachdem es zwischendurch von den hemserbenigen Programmierern, die mal schnell eine Webseite machen wollten, in den Hintergrund gedrängt worden ist. Kommt jetzt wieder wirklich Informatik im Sinne von Informatik als Wissenschaft. Kommt jetzt wieder daher. Und es wird auch wieder viel Aufmerksamkeit und Geld auf Programmierer geworfen, die Lust haben, korrekte Programme zu schreiben, die eben nicht von dem um Russischen HKA...
Gibt es eigentlich auch verschiedene Programmiererstile? Weil es gerade so hemserbenlich ist und Beweise... Ich glaube, es gibt Archetypen der Programmierung. Oder des Programmierer oder Programmiererinnen...
.dass die unterschiedlichen Programmiersprachen und Communities unterschiedliche Programmierer anziehen. Python zum Beispiel ist dafür bekannt, dass das so Leute sind, die niemanden mehr was zu beweisen haben. Du hast wie so C-Programmierer, die Linux machen, die sind meistens so noch so... Jugendliche mit viel Testosteron oder... Und Python-Programmierer sind meistens dann so, ich muss hiermit jetzt... Ich will da keinen Ärger mit haben, ich will was Abgehangenes, was ordentlich dokumentiert ist. Dokumentation ist in Python wirklich sehr wichtig. Und Python hat sich von Anfang an auf die Fahnen geschrieben, wir trieten euch ein bisschen, dass eure Einrückung und der Stil des Programms muss so sein, dass man es am Ende auch wieder leicht lesen kann. Andere Programmiersprachen sind leicht zu schreiben, aber einen Horror zu lesen, so Pearl ist dann ein Standardbeispiel. Das ist wieder ein Insiderwitz, aber das war damals, wenn du Systemadministrator warst und schnell Logfiles auswerten wolltest, dann hast du in Pearl das Pearlscript, das ist so ein stehender Begriff für unlesbaren Wust, schnell in Pearlscript zusammengehackt und die Variablen waren möglichst immer nur ein Buchstabe, möglichst viele Sonderzeichen, viel Magie, die passiert durch möglichst wenig Zeichen. Und wenn du zwei Wochen später drauf geguckt hast, dann bist du so zum Geier.
Es gab früher auch mal so einen Wettbewerb, wo es darum ging, ein Programm zu schreiben, was aussieht, als würde es eine Sache tun, aber in Wirklichkeit eine andere Sache tut. Und zwar möglichst so, dass man es möglichst nicht verstehen kann. Ich glaube, es gibt wahrscheinlich immer noch den Office-Code des... Genau. Und es gibt auch, weil du sagst, verschiedene Stile, es gibt auch tatsächlich, du kannst zum Teil anhand der Programme schon unterscheiden, wer hat dieses Programm geschrieben. Aber das nur nebenbei. Ich denke, es gibt immer einen Nutzen oder einen Zweck, wofür man irgendeine Sprache benutzt. Und danach sollte man meiner Meinung nach auch die Sprache dann auswählen. Also, wie gesagt, das sind Leute, die sich aufgegeben haben, die Python benutzen, aber das muss nicht so sein.
Nein, das sind Leute, die nichts mehr zu beweisen haben.
Das geht auch nicht. Also es gibt einfach für bestimmte Zwecke gibt es Sachen, die einfach zu lernen, gut zu benutzen sind. Und dafür sollte man die auch benutzen.
Aber gibt es, also ist alternd Programmiersprachen eigentlich? Also es gibt ja von Programmiersprachen habe ich jetzt irgendwie gelernt, auch verschiedene Versionen, aber wenn die auch alten, dann sag mal, okay, das macht man heute eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ja, ich kann noch alte Programmiersprachen wie Fortran 77, die niemand mehr benutzt aus gutem Grund. Und das sollte auch nicht mehr verwendet werden. Es gibt eben noch, ja der Grund ist eben, es gibt Libraries, es gibt Bibliotheken, die bestimmte Sachen sehr gut und sehr schnell machen. Und da gibt es dann Leute, die das wiederum noch benutzen. Oder es gibt so Legacy Code. Gibt es ja auch in Kobol irgendwie, das war irgendwie zur Jahrtausendwende so ein Problem. Sachen, die einfach niemand jemals wieder anfassen will und naja, die eben noch in einer ganz alten Sprache geschrieben sind. Aber so würde man das heutzutage nicht mehr machen. Muss man auch nicht mehr, weil die Rechner schneller sind.
Gibt es andererseits Trendsprachen? Also sozusagen die cool gefunden werden, weil also so die Fixies unter den Programmiersprachen, niemand fällt auf zu sagen, Fixies, aber das ist doch was meiner.
Ja, grad akut ist so Go und Rust wird grad gehypt. Vor fünf Jahren war Ruby der heiße aktuelle Kram. Und PHP war dann davor der heiße Kram. Und du siehst, dass da auch mal Probleme mitkommen. Weil wenn es zu sehr gehypt ist, dann hast du dieses Hammer-Nagel-Problem, dass irgendjemand dann genau ein Werkzeug gelernt hat und jetzt alle Probleme damit erschlagen möchte, ob es brauchbar ist oder nicht. Und deswegen war vorhin ging ja die Frage rum, ob man sich viele Programmiersprachen angucken sollte. Natürlich, man sollte sich erstens viele Programmiersprachen angucken. Man muss nicht unbedingt darin programmieren und viele Bibliotheken, um zu gucken, welche Sprachen bringen, welche Werkzeuge mit uns und für welches Problem vielleicht geeignet. Deswegen sich da so ein Überblick zu verschaffen ist, wenn man die Zeit hat und jetzt nicht ganz dringend was mal implementieren muss. Einfach mal durch den Garten stapfen. Der Programmiersprachen und Frameworks ist eigentlich immer eine gute Idee.
Man kann sich auch mit jemandem unterhalten.
Das ist nicht der erste Schritt. Man sollte wahrscheinlich schon eine Programmiersprache ein bisschen können, bevor man sich anguckt.
Das ist genau wie mit Sprache lernen. Also wie mit menschlichen Sprachen lernen. Du machst dir auch nicht Englisch und Französisch gleichzeitig.
Du, Nana, wolltest du noch unbedingt was zu Haskell sagen? Warum? Ist das besonders einsteigerfreundlich?
Nein, das ist wirklich eine von diesen Sprachen, die so... Also mir fällt es schwer, das zu verstehen, aber das kommt, weil ich eben nicht funktionale Programmierung gelernt habe. Es ist diese Sprache, wo er Erdgeist von berichtet hat, die eben sehr sicher ist und die für also für sicherheitsrelevante Anwendungen dann auch benutzt werden kann. Und hat eben sehr viele Vorurteile, die beispielsweise Java nicht hat.
Das sind aber, wenn wir jetzt da wieder draufgucken, sind diese Sprachfamilien ja immer orientiert an der Historie auch. Also du hast immer so Sprachfamilienklassen, wo du die Evolution beobachten kannst.
Aber das ist schon dann was für Fortgeschrittene, oder? Also Sprachfamilienklasse, die Evolution beobachten?
Es gibt große Worte dafür, dass einfach nur hat jemand wie eine neue Version erfunden und wollte nicht, dass die Leute, die die alte Programmiersprache gelernt haben, komplett wie die, wie der Ox vorm Berg stehen und nicht wissen, was jetzt tippen müssen, sondern haben dann einfach bestimmte Konstrukte, wie man Schleifen beschreibt, wie man Variablen beschreibt, haben sie einfach von der alten Sprache übernommen, auch wenn es unter der Haube dann was anderes macht. Und dann siehst du, dass einige Programmiersprachen an C orientiert sind, andere an einer älteren Sprache namens Lisp. Und hast du dann üblicherweise, je nachdem wie die Konzepte voneinander erben, also wie die Konzepte übernommen worden sind und wie bestimmte Konstrukte in der Sprache übernommen worden sind, siehst du diese Klassen dann schon. Und kannst dann einige Programmiersprachen leichter lernen, weil du schon aus der Klasse eine gelernt hast, als eine andere zum Beispiel.
Ok, also das ist tatsächlich sagen Englisch und Französisch dann vielleicht einfacher.
Ja, ich wollte nochmal, weil hier oft dann gerade gesagt wurde, irgendwie eine Sprache ist besonders leicht oder irgendwie einfach zu lernen. Und da hat mal eine Freundin von mir gesagt, dass sie das schwierig findet oder dass sie dann den Eindruck hatte, wenn sie dann was verstanden hat und andere Leute sagen, das ist total leicht, dann motiviert sie das gar nicht so sehr, weil sie dann darin ihre Bemühungen, das eben zu verstehen, da hinzukommen, irgendwie sozusagen unterschätzt sieht. Und das fand ich irgendwie ganz, also für sich, sie hat für sich gesprochen und da muss jeder für sich selbst sprechen können. Aber ich fand es auch ganz wichtig, dass man sich irgendwie dessen bewusst ist, wenn man eben sagt, die Sprache ist ganz leicht zu verstehen oder irgendwas ist besonders schwer oder einfach oder so, dass man immer im Kopf hat, dass Leute mit ganz verschiedenen Vorwissen an solche oder ans Programmieren überhaupt rankommen und dass das vielleicht auch demotivieren kann. Und ich tatsächlich auch manchmal da sitze und dachte, jetzt sitze ich da seit einem Jahr und hab's immer noch nicht verstanden. Und alle sagen, es ist total leicht. Genau. Und ich dann denke, okay, ist es vielleicht doch nicht das Richtige für mich, soll ich damit aufhören?
Da würde ich jetzt gerne zu dem Punkt mit der Hürde kommen, den ich vorhin angesprochen habe, weil das halte ich auf ein ganz, ganz, ganz wichtiges Problem. Mich erinnert das, ich habe früher im Studium sozusagen mal die wilde Idee gehabt, Mathe im Nebenfach zu studieren. War in der ersten Vorlesung und dann ist sozusagen zwei Stunden lang passiert, dass der Professor gesagt hat, wie man leicht sieht, dann hat er so eine wilde Zahlenkarte, die wir angeschrieben haben. Ich hab nicht mal die Grundlage davon verstanden. Und dann hab ich so, okay, das ist nichts für mich. Und tatsächlich ist das auch, glaube ich, eine Schwierigkeit beim Programmieren. Man lernt die Einstiegskonzepte. Also man lernt irgendwie, wie man wohin springt, was eine Schleife ist und so. Und dann, also hab ich es so erlebt und ich kenne auch viele Leute, die von frisierter kommen, gibt es so einen Sprung auf einmal. Okay, jetzt kannst du das Ding, jetzt programmier doch mal den Klonkulator, der die Frumpturation im Speicherlieg kompromittiert. Und man weiß nicht mehr, wo es geht.
Das ist aber ein Problem, das ist eigentlich nur schlechte Didaktik. Das ist ja in vielen anderen Bereichen auch so, wenn du die so malst. Was war das vorhin, wie malt man eine Eule? W2-Kreise für die Augen, wie oben die Ohren ran und dann den Rest der Eule.
Ja genau. Aber so kommt man es beim Programmieren tatsächlich ganz viel vor. Auch wenn ich Online-Tutorials geklickt habe, war das oft so hier.
Das liegt dann aber glaube ich nicht an der Programmiersprache, sondern das ist das Tutorial-Ufer.
Genau, aber das ist ja anscheinend ein verbreiteter Effekt. Und die Frage ist natürlich, wie umgeht man den?
Gibt es eine Wissenschaft zu?
Also ein gutes Tutorial sollte natürlich immer so aufgebaut sein, dass der nächste Schritt ganz logisch auf den nächsten folgt. Also dass es wirklich die einfachste Möglichkeit ist, irgendwie von A nach B zu kommen. Und das ist, wie Erdgeist schon sagt, die Aufgabe vom Tutorial. Wenn das nicht hinbekommt, dann ist es nicht gut. Was ganz gut immer ist, finde ich, ist, wenn man sich vernetzt. Das machen wir auch beim Cola-Dojo, dass man immer Leute hat, die dabei sind oder die man mal fragen kann oder wo man sich einfach mal Rat holen kann, weil man oft an irgendeiner Kleinigkeit sitzt, wo man sich vielleicht viel zu viel Gedanken macht. Und in Wirklichkeit ist es aber ganz einfach und man kann jemanden fragen und der kann einem dann weiterhelfen.
Aber das heißt eigentlich sozusagen, den Beteiligten an diesem Ding, ich würde dir jetzt zwei bitten. Das eine ist sagen, liebe Programmier-Lerner-Anfänger, traut euch zu fragen. Liebe Programmier-Könner, bitte sagt nicht als allererstes, es ist doch ganz einfach.
Ich will immer den Leuten noch Mut machen. Ich will sagen, es ist nicht schwer und ihr könnt es auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das ist glaube ich auch was anderes zu sagen, du kannst das, ne? Und dass du irgendwie als Mentorin, als Mentor irgendwie an die Leute herantrittst und sagst, ich gebe dir jetzt das hundertprozentige Vertrauen, du kannst programmieren. Du musst da halt hinkommen irgendwie, aber du kannst das. Und das andere ist zu sagen, das ist total leicht.
Ich finde da gerade noch ein wichtiger Punkt angesprochen worden, der diese Community, die einen bei der Hand nimmt, die gibt es ja nicht nur für Leute, die dir jetzt explizit Programmieren beibringen, sondern auch als Nebeneffekt, dass du dich an Open Source Projekten beteiligst. Es gibt Communities für größere Projekte, wo man sich einbringen kann, ohne eine Zeile Code zu schreiben, indem man zum Beispiel Übersetzungen macht, indem man Dokumentationen nachliest und sagt, hier, das hat nicht verstanden. Und dann sagt, du Programmierer, das habe ich nicht verstanden, erklär mal nochmal anders. Und so eins der größeren Betriebssysteme FreeBSD macht es genauso, die lockt dort auch potentielle Programmierer an, indem sie sagt, ey, beteilige dich erstmal mit UserDoku für die Werkzeuge. Und wenn du dann diese Tools zum Programmieren grob beherrschst, dann guck mal, muss es ja nicht nur UserDoku sein, sondern auch die Kommentare im Code selber. Kannst ja mal gucken, ob du die verstehst. Wenn nicht, machst du Anmerkungen. Und so locken die seit 15 Jahren erfolgreich Programmierer in ihre Sphären. Weil wenn du dann erstmal dabei bist und den Code versuchst zu verstehen, indem du die Dokumentation liest, dann kannst du auch sagen, aber das stimmt auch nicht über einen. Dann muss man diese Zeile noch mit ändern und dann bist du plötzlich mitten beim Programmieren, ohne dass du es gemerkt hast.
Okay, also was übrigens immer zwischendurch immer wieder durchklingt, ist zu sagen, wenn man nicht für sich selbst programmiert, dann muss man Code auch, also Programmiercode, den man geschrieben hat, auch kommentieren. Also so hinschreiben, dass man ihn lesen kann. Wir haben jetzt einen Steffen am Telefon, der, ich weiß nicht genau, was uns gleich erzählt wird, aber er programmiert zumindest auch. Hallo und guten Abend Steffen.
Hallo, ich hab eure Sendung nicht von Anfang an mitgehört. Ich programmiere zum Beispiel HPV.
Nee, was ist das?
Das ist eine grafische Postmiersprache, analog zu LabView. Die ist in den 90er Jahren aufgekommen von Hewlett Packard. Die heißen jetzt Agilent oder Keysight. Die Entwicklungsumgehung läuft halt noch. Ich hab das auf Arbeit gebraucht, weil wir die Spektrumanalysatoren und die elektronischen Geräte von HP haben. Und da war halt schon mal die Kommunikation zwischen Rechner und Geräte sehr gut geregelt halt. Und davor hab ich in der Schule CC++ gelernt. Und ich hab dann Commodore am Anfang, hab HP Besig auch gemacht. Und eigentlich bin ich halt Elektroniker. Und ich sag halt immer, das Gute ist, um programmieren zu lernen, ist halt Motivation zu haben, zum Beispiel auf Arbeit, dass man irgendwelche Dinge, die einen echt ankotzen, durch Programmierung erleichtern kann. Zum Beispiel in meinem Fall ist es, ich bin halt Messtechniker. Und wenn man überlegt, man macht eine ganze Messreihe mit 50 Dateien. Und als ich angefangen hab, musste ich die Dateien alle einzeln zusammenfassen. Oder ich musste die in Excel darstellen und mehrere Dateien in Excel reinkopieren. Und dann hat man halt die Motivation, das zu automatisieren. Und das treibt einen ganz gut voran.
Die besten Programmierer sind die faulsten Schweine.
Ja, das ist total sinnvoll.
Und ich würde sagen, ich sitze heute noch davor und freue mich, wenn die Funktion einfach läuft.
Aber was würdest du jemandem empfehlen, der jetzt Programmieren von Null auf Lernen will? Wie soll ich das am besten anfangen? Was für ein Tipp hast du für diese Leute?
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich, es gibt ja ganz viele Bereiche, wo man programmieren kann. Ich denke mal, der, der anfangen soll, der muss auch irgendwo die Motivation haben. Dass er halt irgendwas Sinnvolles damit anfangen kann. Als ich zum Beispiel einen Commodore hatte, habe ich mir auch ein Programmierbuch gekauft mit Basic. Und da bin ich einfach dann hängen geblieben, weil ich habe dann irgendeinen Sprite programmiert oder so einen springenden Punkt. Aber dann habe ich gedacht, das ist ja nichts Sinnvolles. Dann bin ich halt damals als Jugendlicher davon wieder abgekommen halt. Dann habe ich wie gesagt in der Technikerschule dieses C++ so ein bisschen gemacht. Und dann konnte man halt ein paar Rechenbeispiele und Textboxen und dann konnte man so ein paar Sachen halt machen. Aber den richtigen Schub hatte ich dann halt erst durch die Arbeit bekommen halt. Und da hatte ich dann in der Technikerschule, da hatte ich halt Lab für gelernt. Auf Arbeit habe ich dann die andere Grafische Programmiersprache. Aber man hat dann auf jeden Fall ein Ziel, was man erreichen will halt. Und ich sage jetzt mal so, zum Beispiel wenn man Anfänger ist vielleicht und man hat mit Excel zu tun als Schüler oder als Kind, dann muss man vielleicht auch Diagramme formatieren oder andere Sachen. Und das sind ja immer viele Klicks, die immer gleich sind. Also kann man vielleicht anfangen, ein Makro aufzuzeichnen und dann ein Makro zu schreiben halt auch.
Also Stefan sagt, man soll, wenn man programmieren anfängt, immer ein Ziel haben und es lohnt sich tatsächlich auch, faul zu sein. Und wenn ich das so erdgeißig verstanden habe, kann er das bestätigen. Als Programmiermotivation. Na gut, dann machen wir an dieser Stelle nochmal eine kleine Pause für die Nachrichten und dann für die Nerd-News und reden danach nochmal ganz konkret darüber, wie man das jetzt oder womit man das anfangen kann, programmieren zu lernen.
Als er noch klein und unbekannt war, spielte er vor einer Handvoll von euch ein lauschiges Radiokonzert in den Fritz-Studios. Und schon damals haben wir gesagt, Und was haben wir gehabt? Recht haben wir gehabt. Fritz präsentiert Ed Sheeran Live in Berlin Montag, 27. März Ed Sheeran Live in der Bands Arena Ed.
Sheeran US-Präsident Trump will den Bau der Mauer an der Grenze zu Mexiko durch Strafzölle finanzieren. Auf alle mexikanischen Waren solle ein Zoll von 20 Prozent erhoben werden, sagte Trumps Sprecher am Abend. Auf diese Weise könnten jährlich 10 Milliarden Dollar eingenommen werden, womit sich der Grenzwahl leicht bezahlen lasse. Der mexikanische Präsident Nieto hatte vorher ein Treffen mit Trump abgesagt. Er will die Milliardenkosten für den Bau der Mauer nicht übernehmen. Der Bundestag hat den Bundeswehreinsatz im westafrikanischen Mali verlängert. Alle Fraktionen mit Ausnahme der Linken stimmten dafür, dass künftig bis zu 1000 deutsche Soldaten in Mali stationiert werden. Bisher waren es 650. Die UN-Mission gilt zurzeit als gefährlichster Einsatz der Bundeswehr. Auch die Ausbildungsmission im Nordirak wurde verlängert. Bei seinem Abschiedsbesuch in Frankreich hat Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier vor den Gefahren des Populismus in Europa gewarnt. Die bevorstehenden Präsidentschaftswahlen in Frankreich seien nicht nur für Frankreich wichtig, sondern für ganz Europa, sagte Steinmeier am Abend in Paris. Laut aktuellen Umfragen dürfte die rechtsextreme Marine Le Pen im Mai in die Stichwahl um die französische Präsidentschaft einziehen. An seinem letzten Abend im Ministeramt wurde Steinmeier in Paris mit dem Verdienstorden der französischen Ehrenlegion ausgezeichnet. Nach dem Fall Holm sollen alle Abgeordneten des neuen Berliner Landesparlaments auf eine frühere Stasi-Mitarbeit geprüft werden. Einen entsprechenden Antrag haben die Koalitionsfraktionen SPD, Linke und Grüne gestellt. Die Abgeordneten müssen aber zustimmen, dass sie überprüft werden. Vor 10 Tagen war Andrej Holm nach nur 5 Wochen im Amt des Baustartsekretärs zurückgetreten. Er hatte falsche Angaben über seine Stasi-Vergangenheit gemacht. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen im Berlin-Köpenick minus 2 Grad und in Charlottenburg minus 1 Grad, in Frankfurt-Oder und Brück minus 3 Grad, in Prenzlau minus 2 Grad und in Küritz minus 1 Grad. Am Abend und in der Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken am Himmel, es bleibt aber meist trocken. Nachts kann es noch auf bis zu minus 10 Grad abkühlen, morgen früh ist es erst ziemlich neblig. Später kommt aber auch mal die Sonne durch, bei Temperaturen zwischen 0 und 3 Grad. Auf der A115 ist im Dreieck Funkturm die Überleitung zur A100 Richtung Wedding wegen Arbeiten an einer Brücke bis ca. 2 Uhr nachts gesperrt. Und auf der A10 südlicher Berliner Ringen Richtung Dreieck Werder gibt es zwischen Dreieck Nutetal und Färch an einer Nachtbaustelle bis 5 Uhr früh nur eine freie Spur. Außerdem fährt in Berlin die U-Bahnlinie 6 bis Ende des Monats nicht zwischen den Bahnhöfen Wedding und Kurt Schumacherplatz. Stattdessen könnt ihr den Bus nehmen. Ein unterwegs, ne gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RWB.
Und zum Chaosradio gehören auch die Nerd-News, beschrieben vom Chaos Computer Club, präsentiert von Johanna Tesma.
US-Präsident Trump hat den Netzneutralitätskritiker Ajit Pai zum Vorsitzenden der Regulierungsbehörde Federal Communications Commission berufen. Pai ist Gegner der Netzneutralitätsregeln, die sein Vorgänger Tom Wheeler gegen den Widerstand der Industrie durchgesetzt hatte. Laut Pai soll die Politik nur im Notfall eingreifen, denn Regulierungspolitik müsse sich an der Realität des Marktes orientieren. Union plant Pflicht zur Richtigstellung von Fake News. Die CDU-CSU-Bundestagsfraktion will soziale Netzwerke verpflichten, ihren Nutzern Richtigstellungen anzuzeigen, wenn der Nutzer zuvor Nachrichten gesehen hat, die als gefälscht identifiziert worden sind. Facebook plant lediglich, dass Nutzer einen Warnhinweis angezeigt bekommen sollen, wenn sie Fake News teilen wollen. Nach den Unionsplänen sollen auch nachträglich alle Nutzer, die Fake News angezeigt bekommen haben, darüber informiert werden. Das meldet der Spiegel. Chaos Computer Club im Visier der Geheimdienste. Die Bürgerrechtsorganisation Büro Jansen & Jansen berichtet, dass der niederländische Inlandsgeheimdienst AIVD versucht, Informanten anzuwerben, die deutsche Hacker-Spaces ausspionieren sollen. Eine betroffene Person sagte der Organisation, sie solle den Auftrag bekommen, die Hacker-Spaces des Chaos Computer Clubs zu besuchen und dem AIVD Interna zu berichten. Eine Sprecherin des Geheimdienstes dementierte das gegenüber netzpolitik.org. Linus Neumann, Sprecher des Chaos Computer Clubs, sagte, die Quellen des Chaos Computer Clubs beim AIVD hätten schon im Voraus Warnungen ausgesprochen. Deswegen sei man nur mäßig überrascht. Der Chaos Computer Club freue sich aber, dass ein weiterer Versuch der Unterwanderung an den hohen moralischen Prinzipien der Community gescheitert sei.
Und wenn ihr am Sonntagnachmittag zocken und lachen wollt, dann macht das doch bei den Sonntagsfritzen mit Kathrin Thüring und Jakob Lund und mit mir, dem Stimulator. Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr auf Fritz.
Fritz Heute Chaosradio in Blumun noch eine halbe Stunde reden wir über das Programmieren lernen und zu Gast sind Marie, Nana und Erdgeist. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück! Wir haben ja schon über verschiedene Dinge gesprochen, die alle zu wiederholen jetzt zu lange dauern würde, deswegen hört euch den Podcast an unter fritz.de oder chaosradio.ccc.de, der am Laufe der Nacht noch erscheinen wird. Zu den verschiedenen Programmiersprachen ist noch eine Frage über die Studiomessage reingekommen und zwar Borland Delphi. Anscheinend wurde jemand damit geschlagen, wenn ich es richtig verstehe. Was ist das? Kann das? Was? Soll man das lieber wegwerfen?
Du bist halt auch alt. Also ich habe ja vorhin so eine Zeitlinie in die Vergangenheit mal aufgespannt für die letzten 15 Jahre. Das war noch davor.
Frühe 90er Jahre, ne? Das muss man jetzt nicht mehr lernen. Also wenn man jetzt anfängt...
Aber wenn man es kann, dann kann man mir schon dreihig werden.
Wieso?
Legacy Code. Also es gibt immer noch irgendwo was, was noch rumliegt, was in Delphi geschrieben ist. Aber jetzt als neue Sprache, nein.
Okay, jetzt ist es ja so, also gerade wenn man vielleicht noch in die Schule geht oder an der Uni gerade angefangen haben, dass dann so Dinge vorgesetzt werden, wo man so denkt, oh nein, bitte nicht. Aber gibt es dann sozusagen Tipps, wie man damit umgehen kann?
Das ist sehr schwer. Also viele von den Informatik-Ramenplänen, also den Lehrplänen, sind sehr alt, zum Teil über zehn Jahre alt und die werden auch nicht so schnell erneuert. Also das ist immer das Problem, dass das seine Zeit dauert, bis sich die Leute da geeinigt haben. Das heißt, man kann natürlich in der Schule, dann muss man vielleicht Delphi lernen. Das habe ich auch schon von Leuten gehört. Und das ist dann, da muss man eben diskutieren. Dann kann man vielleicht fragen, kann ich das Ganze auch in Java abliefern?
Also grundsätzlich sind wir wieder in den Bogen. Zum Anfang der Sendung ist ja Programmieren, das Lösen von Problemen und welches Werkzeug man dann benutzt, ist dem Informatik-Lehrer quasi egal.
Na, das halte ich tatsächlich für ein Gerücht.
Moment, wenn du das, ich hab's falsch formuliert, dass er dir grad ein Werkzeug aufzwingt, was du sonst nicht benutzen kannst, ist ihm egal, sondern er will, dass du das dann mal gerade in der Programmiersprache, wo er das Lösungsheft für hat, abliefert.
Das ist auch gemein den Lehrern gegenüber. Es steht tatsächlich in den Plänen drin, welche Sprachen man benutzen darf. Und da muss man sich eventuell mit arrangieren. Das ist leider nicht alles so leicht. Da gibt es auch für die Politik vielleicht als Anregung, ein bisschen schneller die Pläne erneuern.
So damit sind wir eigentlich schon auch beim Thema der letzten halbe Stunde. Man kann also primär in der Schule lernen. Das tut dann vielleicht weh. Ihr habt aber noch verschiedene Projekte und oder Webseiten oder Dinge mitgebracht, die einem das vielleicht einfach machen können. Bitte.
Ich kann mal nochmal was erzählen. Was immer sehr, sehr schön und lustig ist, auch wieder für Kinder und Jugendliche, ist Code Combat. Bei Code Combat kann man verschiedene Sprachen einstellen, zum Beispiel auch Python. Und man kann, es ist als Spiel aufgebaut, das heißt, man ist da, glaube ich, in so einer Fantasy-Welt. Man kann ein Ritter oder eine Ritterin sein und bewegt sich da so durch Verliese. Und man lernt gleichzeitig eben bestimmte Strukturen der Sprache. Man lernt, wie man irgendwie eine Schleife programmiert oder eine Bedingung oder sowas. Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schön zu spielen und zu lernen. Es gibt...
Klingt nach einer Sache für mich.
Ja, es macht so viel Spaß.
Machst du was mit Spielen?
Vielleicht, manchmal?
Man kann auch JavaScript zum Beispiel damit lernen. Also vielseitig. Es gibt die Webseite code.org, die hat immer die Hour of Code, also eine Stunde programmieren, da gibt es... Das ist auch für kleinere Kinder geeignet. Da gibt es immer was mit Disney, mit Elsa und Anna oder mit, wie heißt dieser neue Film, Moana. Was mit Minecraft, alles Mögliche. Das ist für die kleineren Kinder ganz hübsch. Sollten allerdings schon ein bisschen lesen können. Haben wir noch was für die Älteren auch?
Na, für die Älteren gibt es im Internet tatsächlich, glaube ich, sehr viel am Tutorials. Und es gibt für Ruby, wie ein Wunder, das trialruby.org, also einfach zusammengeschrieben probierruby sozusagen auf englisch, trialruby.org. Und das ist wirklich ein sehr, da kannst du auch danach noch nicht wirklich richtig Ruby, aber es vermittelt dir so ein erstes Gefühl dafür, wie das funktionieren kann. Das heißt, es sagt dir ganz genau, was jetzt gerade passiert, und du tippst das einfach nur ab, was dir vorgegeben wird und siehst dann, wie das sozusagen, diesen Code, den du eingibst, was dabei halt herauskommt, was das Resultat ist. Und das kann so eine sehr einfach, aus meiner Perspektive, sehr einfache spielerische Art sein, sich damit überhaupt mal auseinanderzusetzen. Also wirklich ein Einstiegslevel. Es gibt dann aber auch eben Tutorials, also praktisch eigentlich ganze Bücher, die online stehen, zum Beispiel learnrubythehardway.org.
Das klingt ja total schmeichelhaft.
Ja, das ist auch, also klar, es gibt Leute, die sagen, ich finde das nicht so schlau, wenn man sagt, learn it the hard way. Das ist ein bisschen abschreckend. In dem Fall geht es aber darum, dass man tatsächlich kleinteilig vorgeht und nicht davon ausgeht, dass irgendwie die Leute schon sehr viel Vorwissen mitbringen. Es gibt viele Tutorials, die irgendwie auch eigentlich schon annehmen, dass du schon eine andere Sprache kannst und dass dann einfach irgendwie schon weißt, wie zum Beispiel so eine Schleife funktioniert oder andere Konzepte. Die haben mir immer nie geholfen, weil ich das eben nicht hatte so.
Ich glaube, eins bei dem The Hard Way ist auch der Aspekt, dass man die Sachen tatsächlich selber abtippen muss und soll. Du lachst, aber es ist tatsächlich sehr verbreitet heutzutage. Das mache ich natürlich niemals, dass man Sachen copy und pastet, ohne sie wirklich abzutippen oder auch zu verstehen. Und es funktioniert tatsächlich besser. Man lernt es besser, wenn man es selber tippt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich kann schon sozusagen den Ansatz verstehen, dass man sagt, du lernst es, wenn es einmal durch deine Finger gefloßen ist. Aber wenn der Archetyp des faulen Programmierers auf einen Leitfaden stößt, der ihn zwingt, Programmcode abzutippen, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es dazu Interessen konzentriert.
Du kannst ganze Programmiererkarrieren drauf aufbauen, einfach nur von dieser Stack Overflow Community Seite. Ich kenne gleich Programmierer-Spiele, einfach raus zu kopieren und deinen Code einzufügen. Dann hast du gewonnen. Stack Overflow ist eine Webseite von Programmierern für Programmierer. Einfach so ein Forum im Web, wo man Fragen stellt und Bonuspunkte bekommt, wenn man die richtige oder als richtig akzeptierte Antwort gegeben hat.
Es gibt immer so diesen Spruch, wenn Stack Overflow down ist, dann haben alle Programmierer früher frei.
Ich dachte, da müssen sie länger arbeiten.
Nein, dann müsste man ja was selber machen.
Aber sag mal, das bringt mich zu einem Punkt, weil es taucht immer wieder auf, wenn man also Libraries oder sucht sich auf dieser Stack Overflow-Seite vielleicht Dinge und kopiert die dann. Ist das tatsächlich eine Empfehlung? Also ist das auch oder andersrum gesagt, ist das ist das Teil der praktischen Programmierarbeit, dass man eigentlich nicht sozusagen alles selber schreibt, sondern dass der größere Teil eigentlich ist, okay, ich brauche eine Problemlösung und dann gucke ich, was davon alles schon gemacht wurde, stecke das zusammen und sorge für die ordentliche Verbindungsstücke?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es macht auch Sinn, weil oft haben die Leute, die die Libraries geschrieben haben, auch wirklich Arbeit und Kopf da reingesteckt und machen es so, wie es richtig ist. Und das, gerade wenn man so jetzt sicherheitsrelevante Sachen irgendwie ausprobiert oder so, man denkt, oh, ich könnte es ja so und so machen, aber das haben ganz viele andere Leute schon gedacht.
Ich finde es wichtig, dass du es ansprichst, weil das ist gerade eines der großen Probleme, das ist für mich das GitHub-Problem. GitHub ist so eine Seite, die es einfach macht, Programme, die man selber geschrieben hat, im Internet mal zu verbreiten und kollaborativ mit anderen Leuten an seinem Projekt weiterzuarbeiten. Und da ist eine große Gefahr da drin, weil da einfach keine Qualitätssicherung passiert. Und jeder und sein Hund haben natürlich irgendwann früher mal eine Bibliothek geschrieben, um Datumsformate ineinander überzuführen, um zu gucken, was für ein Wochentag war der, der ja nur 1970, keine Ahnung, haben Leute hingeschrieben, sich gefreut, oh super, hab ich verstanden, veröffentlichen das und andere Leute benutzen das. Und das ist ein großes Problem, weil das, was ich damals programmiert hab, als ich noch klein war, das hat glücklicherweise nie das Licht der Öffentlichkeit entdeckt. Da ist bis jetzt auch der gädige Gott des Bitrotts ist da drüber gegangen und auf das Ketten, die man nicht mehr lesen kann, ist das weg. Und heutzutage, wenn du als 12- 13-Jähriger anfängst zu programmieren und du wirst dazu animiert, das auf diese Seiten hochzuladen, jemand anders kommt vorbei, sieht, oh, da hat jemand mein Problem gelöst, nimmt diese Bibliothek und benutzt sie in seinem Projekt und scheitert dann an den lustigsten Stellen. Deswegen ist es doll wichtig zu wissen und jemanden zu haben, der einem hilft, dabei einzuschätzen, welche Bibliotheken...
Woran erkenne ich, dass die Bibliothek gut ist?
Leider nicht gerade. Es ist gerade echt schwierig, da musst du wirklich jemanden kennen, von dem du die Meinung gebildet hast, dass er sich so ein bisschen auskennt. Und vielleicht alle großen Frameworks, alle Programmiersprachen haben sogenannte Best Practices. Also Stand der Dinge, Guides zusammengestellt, wo sie bestimmte Bibliotheken empfehlen. Das funktioniert in einigen Programmiersprachen besser als in anderen. Ich darf keine Programmiersprachen bashen jetzt gerade, deswegen halte ich mich zurück.
Gut, dann können wir vielleicht noch zu einem positiven Punkt kommen, weil jetzt habt ihr gerade sozusagen dieses Wo, Womit oder Wo kann man programmieren lernen. Habt ihr Webseiten aufgezählt. Aber ich habe am Anfang der Sendung oder zwischendurch wieder gab es so, es gibt diese Veranstaltung, da kann man hinkommen, ohne irgendeine Ahnung zu haben. Also irgendwie Rail Scouts war sowas. Da würde ich zum Beispiel gerne mal wissen, wie läuft denn die konkret ab? Also ich meine, das ist ja schön, dass du sagst, man kann da hinkommen, muss keine Ahnung haben, hinterher kann man irgendwie programmieren. Aber wie genau läuft denn so ein, weiß ich nicht, Tag, Workshop, was auch immer?
Wie läuft das ab? Also in Berlin haben sie tatsächlich ein sehr schönes Konzept einfach erarbeitet und so ein Workshop findet eigentlich immer Samstag statt. Und Freitagabends wird immer schon am Vorabend angeboten, dass man eben sich trifft zur Installation von den Tools, die man dann am nächsten Tag braucht. Und manchmal, damit eben die Zeit da nicht weggenommen wird. Und da kann man sich schon so ein bisschen vorbereiten, ein bisschen kennenlernen. Und am nächsten Tag findet dann so ab, weiß ich nicht, zehn oder so, tatsächlich findet das eigentlich meistens so statt, dass man irgendwie ankommt, seine Gruppe findet, die Coaches dazu findet. Und dann gibt es irgendwie so eine Einführung in was ist vielleicht, was ist eigentlich Programmieren oder so grundsätzliche Konzepte. Zum Beispiel auch, wie funktioniert eigentlich so ein HTTP-Anfrage, ne? Wenn wir irgendwie eine Webseite ansteuern, was passiert da eigentlich? Also so Grundkonzepte. Und dann geht es darum, dass man sich ein Tutorial anschaut, Stück für Stück da durchgeht, in der Gruppe oder vielleicht auch alleine, je nachdem, und dann eben an so einer Rails-App so ein bisschen rumbastelt. Und am Ende, so ist das Tutorial aufgebaut, am Ende hat man dann eben so ein Resultat, was man sehen kann. Dann hat man so eine Karte, so eine Weltkarte, und dann kann man irgendwie, glaube ich, den Namen oder kann man irgendwie so Punkte draufsetzen oder so. Und zwischendurch gibt es dann noch so ein bisschen so Input-Talks von eben Programmierern, die dir eben sagen, irgendwelche Tipps geben oder sagen, wie man am besten irgendwie weiter lernen kann.
Genau.
Und danach, und das ist auch das Schöne daran, weil es ja tatsächlich dann eigentlich nur ein Tag wäre und der ist dann vorbei, bilden sich dann immer solche Study Groups, die sich eben einmal in der Woche treffen und dann genau da ansetzen, wo eben aufgehört wurde an diesem Tag. Und dann geht man da so ein ganzes Tutorial Ruby durch, wo man irgendwie wirklich bei Null anfängt und dann Woche pro Woche weitergeht.
Aber wenn man zu dem Event hin gibt, sagt man auch, okay, ich mach diese Study Groups auch oder kann man das entscheiden?
Auf keinen Fall, nee. Also macht man, wie man mag. Das wird halt dann eben angeboten, gesagt, hey, es gibt wieder eine neue, die eben wieder bei Null anfängt.
Das Coda Dojo, wie genau funktioniert das?
Coda Dojo ist immer ein Nachmittag. Die Kinder oder Jugendlichen kommen vorbei, dann sagen wir kurz was an und wir zeigen die Tutorials. Wir haben so eine Materialsammlung, die ist auch unter codadojo.com. Bei den Berliner Dojos und beim Potsdamer Dojo zumindest gibt es so eine Liste zu finden. Und dann geht's los. Also dann kann man wirklich schon gleich anfangen und man kann das machen, was man möchte. Wenn man keine Idee hat, kann man mal fragen, was könnte ich denn machen? Und dann, es ist selbst gesteuert und selbst organisiert. Das heißt, man macht das, wozu man Lust hat. Und solange man Lust hat. Und am Ende kann man vielleicht dann nochmal zeigen oder präsentieren, wenn man möchte, was man so gebaut hat. Was auch noch eine Sache ist, die ich erwähnen wollte, ist, dass wenn jetzt jemand sagt, oh, das ist eine großartige Idee, ich möchte das gerne in meiner Stadt auch machen, es gibt es aber noch nicht. Das könnt ihr euch einfach an uns wenden, weil jeder kann ein Coda-Dojo eröffnen. Es ist immer kostenlos. Ansonsten braucht man nur einen Raum. Aber in Berlin haben wir mehr Räume, als wir tatsächlich füllen können. Also wenn jemand sagt, ich kann schon ein bisschen programmieren, ich würde gerne mal aushelfen, oder jemand hat Kinder und will, dass die zum Coda-Dojo kommen können, einfach mal uns kontaktieren, und wir können auch beim Einstieg helfen. Oder man kommt einfach so vorbei, was auch total super ist.
Ich muss jetzt mal wieder meine Lanze für Python brechen, dass das Äquivalent zu diesen Ruby-Workshops gibt es auch mit Django Girls, was eigentlich genauso strukturiert ist und in diversen deutschen Städten stattfindet. Django ist ein auf Python basiertes Web-Framework, was ungefähr dieselbe Funktion erfüllt wie Rails für die Programmiersprache Ruby. Und die Python-Community hat sich auch eine Seite gegönnt, auf der diverse Tutorials für Programmierer und für Nicht-Programmierer drinstehen, wie man mit der Sprache anfängt. In dem Wiki sucht man nach Beginners Guide für Programmers oder Non-Programmers. Übersichtliche Liste auch kommentiert, welche gut und welche schlecht sind. Und das hilft dann beim Einstieg in die Programmiersprache Python.
Ich würde noch zwei befreundete Projekte ganz gerne erwähnen. Und zwar einmal, wenn man als Jugendlicher jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr Ahnung hat, schon ein bisschen fortgeschrittener ist, kann man sich mal die Seite von Jugendhackt anschauen, wenn man das noch nicht gemacht hat. Das ist ein wunderbares Projekt. Das gibt im Jahr mehrere Hackathons, wo man mit anderen Jugendlichen zusammenarbeitet, Projekte macht, um die Welt zu verbessern. Ganz großartiges Projekt, Jugendhackt.de. Zweites Projekt, was auch in Berlin gibt, ist die Hearts of Code.
Das wollte ich doch sagen. Die Hearts of Code ist ein Projekt, das vor ungefähr über einem Jahr geboren wurde in Berlin. Das ist eine Initiative, um einen Hackspace für Personen, die sich als Frauen identifizieren, gründen wollen. Im Moment treffen wir uns jeden Donnerstag, so auch heute Abend, im befreundeten X-Hain. Das ist ein Hackspace in Friedrichshain. Da kommen eigentlich immer Frauen vorbei, die sich irgendwie für Technik begeistern und interessieren. Das heißt, da kann man auch unabhängig von einem Workshop oder von einem Event, was vielleicht gerade nicht stattfindet, kann man sich einfach treffen und sagen, hey, ich hab Lust, das und jenes zu machen. Gibt's da nicht jemanden. Da gibt es mittlerweile schon eine ganz stolze Communitygruppe, die sich eben vernetzt und über die man dann eben Gleichgesinnte treffen kann.
Die machen auch immer so tolle Events, wie zum Beispiel wir gehen zusammen in die Seabase oder weil es auch einfacher ist zusammen irgendwo hinzugehen, wenn man sich vielleicht noch nicht so richtig traut. Oder wir machen eine Krypto-Party, wo man lernen kann, was Verschlüsselung bedeutet oder so. Für Frauen, Sternchen.
hardofcode.org oder auf Twitter einfach Hardofcode.
Ist das nicht Hackerinnen?
Ok. Ich will nicht mensplain, aber wir haben jetzt Veranstaltungen für Kids und Jugendliche und für Frauen und solche, die sich als solche identifizieren. Wird davon ausgegangen, Männer können einfach hacken? Oder gibt es auch Events, die genau mit dem Anspruch, ich kann nicht programmieren und ich möchte auch nicht, dass ich ausgelacht werde, weil ich nicht programmieren kann, sagen, wo man das lernen kann?
Da haben wir vorhin drüber geredet und wir wussten nicht so genau.
Na ja, es gibt halt die Open Tech School, die gibt es ja. Das ist einfach auch, würde ich sagen, so eine Initiative oder so eine Community, über die man alle möglichen Workshops eben besuchen kann. Ich habe da zum Beispiel mal einen Einstieg in CSS besucht. Die bieten alles Mögliche an, auch Einstieg in funktionale Programmierung. Und das ist offen für Frauen, Männer und alle dazwischen. Also insofern, ja, es gibt halt immer noch in der Informatik, soweit ich weiß, der aktuelle Stand ist 17% Frauenanteil. Deswegen gibt es da schon auch, das kommt nicht von, wie sagt man, von ungefähr. Das ist so viele Angebote, oder sagen wir mal, dass es ein paar Angebote gibt, die eben für Frauen sind.
Die wollt ihr euch gar nicht in Abrede stellen. Das ist eine technische Frage. Also wenn man halt einfach keine Ahnung hat und sich jetzt diese Sendung hört, denkst du so, hey, das klingt total geil.
Du meinst, wenn man so 35-jähriger Radiomoderator ist?
29, 29.
Eines, was mir noch einfällt, ist ja Minigame Jam. Den gibt es auch in Berlin. Das ist nicht immer nur Computerspiele, sondern generell Spiele entwickeln. Die sind auch sehr nett eigentlich. Wenn man sich jetzt für Computerspiele interessiert ist.
Und da kann man auch hingehen, ohne programmieren zu können? Weil man das sozusagen...
Weil man einfach nur eine Idee hat oder mal gucken möchte oder so.
Es gibt auch alle möglichen User Groups. Und da denke ich, wenn man da mal hingeht und sagt, hey, ich hab Lust, das zu lernen, da trifft man bestimmt auch auf offene Ohren. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Stimmt, so Linux User Groups, die sind wie ganz vorne dabei. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du da irgendjemanden triffst, der irgendeine Programmiersprache beherrscht und dich da mal bei der Hand nimmt, ist nicht so gering.
Okay, dann wissen wir Bescheid, warum haben wir besprochen, was haben wir besprochen und wo haben wir jetzt auch besprochen. Jetzt haben wir noch ein paar Minuten Zeit und entweder könnt ihr jetzt noch ein flammendes Abschlussplädoyer fürs Programmieren lernen halten oder ihr erklärt mir, was es mit den 99 Bierflaschen auf sich hat. Eure Wahl. Ich habe noch nie ein so unsicheres Fragen nach einem flammenden Plädoyer gehört. Aber bitte, los geht's! Das flammende Plädoyer von Nana.
Also programmieren. Man sollte auf jeden Fall keine Angst haben, programmieren lernen zu wollen. Es macht unglaublich viel Spaß. Es ist ein ganz toller Effekt, wenn endlich das passiert, was man immer wollte, das passiert. Ich finde immer, man sollte ein Projekt haben und man will es dann unbedingt bauen. Und da wird man dann auch irgendwie leichter über diese Hürden kommen, wo wir drüber gesprochen haben. Programmieren bedeutet Selbstermächtigung. Ich kann die Welt besser gestalten und ich kann sie auch besser verändern, wenn ich programmieren kann. Es muss sich ja nicht jeder können, aber es gibt, es macht das Leben schöner.
Wenn es nach mir ginge, sollte jeder programmieren lernen. Aber eigentlich ist es erstmal wichtig, grob zu verstehen, dass ein Computer oder die Computer, die man heute im Laden kaufen kann, quasi einen Schritt nach dem nächsten machen. Die holen sich Instruktionen, die man denen irgendwann mal beigebracht hat. Führen die aus, holen sich die nächste, führen die aus. Und da ist keine Magie dabei. Da ist höchstens irgendjemand dabei, der beim Programmieren eines einer Applikationen mal bestimmte Dinge nicht bedacht hat. Und dadurch unnötige Komplexität erzeugt hat. Das heißt, da muss man keine Angst davor haben. Man ist im Zweifel nicht dumm, sondern man ist dort einfach nur leibtragender von dem, was ein Programmierer irgendwann mal falsch gemacht hat. Und man kann es eventuell in einigen Projekten besser machen, indem man sich, wenn man sich doll drüber ärgert, in den Code reinguckt, versucht zu verstehen, was da schief geht und sich vielleicht daran sogar beteiligt, wenn einem dieses Programm doll viel bedeutet.
Ja, ich hab vor zwei Jahren mir mal eine Menstruations-App runtergeladen und dann hat eine Freundin von mir gesagt, das kannst du nicht machen, die spähen deine Informationen aus, lösch die wieder. Ich fand die total toll, ich wollte diese App eigentlich gerne benutzen und war dann aber doch davon überzeugt und hab die App dann wieder gelöscht. Und hab jetzt im Laufe eben mit diesem ganzen Programmieren lernen und so vor glaube ich zwei oder drei Wochen angefangen, eine Open-Source-Mensurations-App zu mir anzuschauen, mir sozusagen den Code zu kopieren und werde das jetzt mit einer Freundin oder mit einer Mitstreiterin sozusagen mir anschauen. Hab eigentlich keine Ahnung von Android. Das ist eine Android-App, aber bin jetzt glaube ich mit dem Grund selbstbewusstsein ausgestattet, mir diese App einfach anzuschauen und munter rumzuhacken. Deswegen kann ich das deswegen auch sehr empfehlen.
Alles klar, löst eure Probleme, lernt, programmieren und hackt munter rum. Ich danke Erdgeist, Nana und Marie, die hier in Wanne übers Programmieren lernen gesprochen haben. Ich danke Dani Mo und Mo, die die Sendung organisiert haben und die NerdNews geschrieben haben. Ich danke Johanne Tesmer, die die NerdNews ganz hervorragend vorgetragen hat und uns durch die Nachrichten geleitet hat. Ich danke euch fürs Zuhören. Ihr könnt den Podcast nochmal runterladen unter fritz.de oder chaosradio.ccc.de Nach uns kommt Jan Schwarzkamp, der euch die Nacht mit Gitarrenmusik erfreuen wird. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
I've clicked more than Douglas Engelbart.
I need the internet like Whitney Houston needs crack.
All my bitches up in the club. Let me see you shaking it, don't stop.
Rub it down, bounce around.
1, 2, Polizei, 3, 4, Voltaire, 5, 6, Pappetex, 7, 8, mit oder?
It's an index finger party.